Hello?
I can't believe I'm willingly playing Five Nights at Freddy's right now.
My manager was like, you did this to yourself.
You live with your consequences.
And now we have to fix your channel!
You did this, Doki.
You wanted to play all these obscured, long-ass series.
Now we need you to chase that algorithm!
Dynasty Warriors come with a cause!
And now you gotta play the new FNAF game!
Cause that's what the algorithm wants, Doki!
That's what they want!
And put on those cat ears!
Cause that's what they want too!
Like...
Let's do!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Yippee!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Speaking of obscured series, how about the Majora's run before July 4th?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Coyote!
I gotta fix my channel first, guys!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
It felt like a terror was building after each loop!
Manny, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I even heard this one was actually scary compared to the past!
Like, no!
No!
Wait!
Okay!
This is also why I'm streaming it in the morning!
I'm already self-sabotaging!
I could have played this at peak NA hours!
But I was like, no!
If you want me to play an algorithm game and that is horror, I'm playing it in the morning!
I'm not playing it at night, chat!
I...
This is my...
Like...
This is...
What's the word?
My part of the deal!
My exception here!
This is...
Like, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Speaking of obscured game, how about some godhead!
My compromise!
This is my...
Sorry!
I'm...
I'm already so scared that I can't English anymore!
This is my compromise!
I'm playing it in the morning!
I'm gonna try to one-shot this!
Cause apparently it's very short for a $50 game!
I was like...
I was reading the reviews and there...
People were like...
How...
They were like...
How are we paying $50 for four hours of gameplay?
And I was like...
Thank fucking god!
I will pay you more money...
To get less of this!
I'll pay...
I'll pay $100 if you manage to make this game two hours!
So...
Yeah, apparently it's four to five hours!
So I'm gonna try and one-shot this!
So I don't have to play it next week!
Um...
JL!
Thank you to the super chat!
Thank you!
Don't be scared!
Just...
Alright!
Okay!
Before we start...
I have...
Um...
A dad update!
So like...
Okay!
So...
Every passing day...
For some reason...
I might actually have to...
Get a personal trainer!
Because...
I don't know what the fuck happened to my dog!
But ever since he broke his back...
He has been getting a...
I feel like he just like...
Life changed for him or something!
Like...
He...
He realized like...
Life is too short!
I'm gonna make it worth my while!
Like...
Like his whole...
Personality...
Started...
Changing...
Every day!
Not changing every day!
I think the better word is that...
He started getting more...
And more...
Bratty...
And like...
Ballsy now!
So...
So he's like...
So he's...
He has realized...
You know...
It's like...
This like...
Life-changing experience!
And now he's like...
That's it!
I'm gonna live my life...
To the fullest!
And like...
Okay...
So...
That update...
Um...
This started yesterday!
And...
Uh...
Basically what happens...
Is that...
Um...
He started stealing...
Other dogs...
Toys now!
In a way...
Where he starts stealing...
Other dogs...
Balls!
And he would never do that before!
So...
He is like...
He sees other...
Other dogs...
Playing fetch...
And he's like...
I want his...
Ball!
He's like...
No!
I wanna play fetch...
Too!
And...
It makes him...
Feel alive!
Doki!
So...
Basically...
Um...
Today...
Uh...
Okay...
Yesterday...
It was very scary...
Because...
The other dog...
Was a very big...
Black dog!
And I was...
Very scared for him!
I knew what he wanted to do...
Too!
He instantly saw...
The owner brought...
Like...
A ball...
To play fetch...
With his...
Her dog...
And then he like...
Went to...
Did a beeline...
Towards the other dog...
And started like...
Stalking him...
Cause he was like...
You're gonna drop that ball...
And when you drop that ball...
I'm gonna...
Take it!
And I got really...
Fucking scared!
Cause that dog was like...
Four times his size!
He's like...
You...
You think I'm scared of you?
I almost died once!
I don't fear death anymore!
But then I'm like...
No Jokey!
No Dad!
You didn't die!
You were just...
Almost paralyzed!
That is different!
This dog can actually kill you!
Like...
And...
So...
So I had to like...
Pick him up...
And like...
Carry him away...
Cause he...
And also he kept like...
He kept like...
Running away from me...
From being picked up...
He would like...
Go in circle...
Around the other dog...
To prevent me from...
Picking him up!
And then like...
When I pick him up...
And then he sees the other dog...
Playing fetch...
He starts barking...
He's like...
No!
It's my ball!
How dare you prevent me from playing fetch!
How dare you!
Anyway...
So...
Okay...
Now today...
Today it got worse...
Today...
He realizes...
That like...
I don't like it when he tries to steal other dog's balls...
So...
Today...
Uh...
So this time...
There were little like...
I think they're called Pug Terriers...
They're not Pugs...
They're like...
Bigger than Pugs...
I don't know...
But they're like...
Sort of like Pugs...
I don't know what breed they are...
I forgot what they are...
Like...
Bulldog Terriers...
I don't know...
Like Pug...
Like they have the Pug face...
Sort of...
But like not fully...
They're not like squeezed in tight.
But like, anyway.
Anyway, that doesn't matter in the story.
And someone was like, ugly dogs.
I'm like, no!
Okay, look.
I don't remember what... and maybe they're French bulldogs.
I don't remember.
Anyway.
Anyway, so this time, it's not... it's a different dog's ball this time.
And this time, maybe dad could take them.
But I also do not want him to fight them.
But like, you know, they're more of his size this time.
So I'm not as scared.
As a fucking giant black dog that could clearly, like, pick him... like, pick him up with his... with his mouth.
And like, maybe like, rip him the pieces.
So I'm not as scared this time.
Anyway.
Um, so the other owner also was trying to play fetch with his dogs.
Like, he had two of them.
And, um, and so he threw the tennis ball.
But, uh, the other two dogs didn't really care about it.
So I was like, alright, whatever.
And then dad was like, watching them.
And...
I was sitting on a bench.
And he was like, watching them.
And he saw that they were like...
Like, you know, he was like, stalking his mark, you know?
Like...
You know when people were doing heists?
And they're like...
They, they like, do like, surveillance and scouting.
So he was scouting them.
Like, at first.
You know, not like yesterday where he went for the fucking beeline towards the big black dog and try to challenge him.
This time, he was like, scouting.
And just seeing his surroundings.
Seeing when he could, he could like, get in there.
Anyway...
So, he, um...
He like, waited.
He actually waited this time.
And...
And he noticed that the other two dogs didn't really care about the ball that much.
So he was like, this is it.
This is my time to shine.
So, he, he just casually...
By the way, yesterday, he was like, running towards the ball and everything.
Today, he was like, casually walking over to the ball that was in the middle of the park.
As if like, you know, just be like, this is just my normal stroll time.
Just casually walking forward nonchalantly.
Like, ooh, just gauging my surroundings.
And he grabbed the ball.
He, he, he grabbed the ball.
And then, and then like, briskly walked towards the exit.
Like...
He was like...
This is...
It was like a fucking heist.
He actually tried to leave the park.
I've never seen him do that before.
He grabbed the ball.
And then instantly went towards the exit.
And, and he was like...
And then...
He was like, come on!
Come on!
And he looked at me and he's like, come on!
And then I walked over to him.
Like, to the exit.
And he was like, you're my getaway driver.
What are you standing here for?
Open the door, Doki!
Open the door!
He kept looking at me at the door.
He's like, what are you doing?
We need to go now!
And I'm like, what the fuck?
I even got a picture of him.
Cause I was like, what the fuck are you...
What the fuck are you doing?
That's so stupid!
Holy shit!
Alright, like...
You see, this is the door!
And he's like, come on!
Open the door!
We gotta leave!
Save him!
Stuck the car!
He kept...
He kept, like, looking at me and the door as if I would fucking open the door for him.
Uh...
He...
Caught in the act.
So, I'm gonna have to get a dog trainer soon.
Because...
I don't know.
He's getting more and more, like, wild and brattier and braver every day.
And...
And I'm like, I don't know what he's gonna do tomorrow.
I...
Like, every day is a new day with him.
Um...
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Your dog is a heister.
He learned from the best.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, he wants to leave.
Okay.
He's like, you're too loud!
Let me out!
Alright, goodbye.
Um...
Uh...
But yeah, now...
Yeah, so...
Today was a wild day.
Um...
And I think he's poop shy, too.
I figured...
I realized that he may or may not be poop shy.
Cause if there's too many dogs at the dog park, he refuses to poop.
And...
I once stayed at the dog park for an hour yesterday.
I stayed at the dog park for an hour.
Just waiting for him to fucking poop.
And then, like, at that moment, there were so many other dogs there, too.
And all he did was just being a fucking terrorist.
Like, he was terrorizing everybody.
Like...
If he wasn't, like, asking for other owners for pets, he was trying to steal other balls.
He was just stealing other balls!
And he hated every...
Any dog that was bigger than him.
He was like, No!
I refuse to let you be taller than me!
And he would actually...
He was actually scaring other big dogs.
Cause the other big dogs were super curious about him.
And then he...
They would, like, come up to him.
And then he would do, like, the...
You know, like, pulling up his, like, teeth.
And he's, like, showing.
He's like, No!
No!
And then, like, you know, the bigger dogs would be like, Oh, look...
Look at this cute little cat.
And then when they get too close, he'd, like, bite...
Like, not bite them, but he'd, like...
And then they, like, instantly run away.
He is...
He has a Napoleon complex.
No, he 100% does.
I...
I don't know what to do with him.
Like, he never was, like, that...
What's the word?
He usually was never...
And then I would be like, I'm sorry.
I don't know why he's so angry.
And to be honest, I'd be like, I'm so sorry.
Yeah, he's...
He's never been, like, that territorial and aggressive.
Before.
So...
So, I...
That's why I was, like, thinking I have to get a dog trainer.
I...
I have no...
Like, ever since he, like, broke his back.
He's a changed man.
He's living each day.
As if, like, there's no consequences anymore.
He doesn't fear anything.
Yeah, he's a grumpy little man.
Anyway, guys.
Today, we are playing Five Nights at Freddy's.
The Secret of the Mimic.
The only Five Nights at Freddy game I played was the first one.
So, I have no idea what this game is about.
I heard that this game has been in development for a while now.
And, um...
And was it made by the same people that did the security breach?
I believe.
I don't know.
I...
I could be lying.
I could be making shit up.
I don't fucking know.
Normal Sized Phantom.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Don't worry, Doki.
There's no shame in crying, fear and running in terror.
There's so much shame in crying, and fear, and running in terror.
Thank you the Super Chat.
Thank you, Thank you.
Alright, time to play.
Secret of the Mimic.
Well, obviously, I assume there's animatronics in here, but also, apparently, there's no Freddy.
So, I think that's... I don't know, that's weird.
A Five Nights at Freddy's game without Freddy.
That's... I don't know.
I don't know how to feel about it.
Oh, yeah, and I played... Yeah, but Into the Pit did not feel like an actual... like a regular FNAF game, you know?
But Into the Pit was really good.
I really enjoyed Into the Pit, but it didn't feel like an actual FNAF game.
It was like... it was like its own thing in general.
Yeah, I'm like, how am I... where am I?
If I'm not... I'm not at Five Nights at Freddy's.
Where am I?
Five Nights at where?
Oh my god, I'm having existential crisis right now.
Where... Where am I?
Wouldn't it be funny if I just play it at this brightness?
Oh my god, if only... Okay, I'll put a little bit bright.
I'll put it at 60.
Five Nights at Murray's.
Can I put a spin on the run from Monster Formula Series?
That's gone full circle.
Oh, hey, there's... There's... Oh my god.
Scott... No, not Scott.
The purple guy.
I was like... No, it's... Fuck.
He was in Dead by Daylight.
Springtrap.
Yes.
Okay, guys.
This is... I swear to god, I'm not a poser.
I... I swear to god.
Guys, I'm not... I'm not a poser, guys.
I know my FNAF lord.
That bite of 35.
Yeah, William Afton.
There we go.
There's William Afton.
Purple guy.
Leah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
Try not to get... It's... Get lost.
It's dark out here.
Guys, I swear to... I'm such a legit fan.
I know all about the bite of 34.
All right.
Toggle.
I'll do press and hold.
Uh... Press and hold.
No head bop.
I don't fucking care about the immersiveness.
What are you talking about?
Fake fans?
Sorry.
I meant the bite of 39.
There you go.
That has to be the right number.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
There's not a lot of controls.
Was that the bite of 69?
Oh, that's a different type of bite.
Sorry.
Let me turn the jump scare a little low.
I... Look, it's not... I'm not... I'm not cheating.
I just don't wanna fucking... Make my ears bleed.
I already had Dad barking in my ears.
Do not bite.
Sorry.
That was a different game, guys.
That was Five Nights at somewhere else.
Five... Five Nights at Freaky.
How... Why is that so tiny?
I said yes subtitles.
How does that help anybody?
How... How...
I'm struggling to stay awake.
What?
I might as well turn off subtitles.
That's tiny.
Awesome to hear.
Well, listen.
We need you to take one more shift for us.
Since you're our closest... Did I put it at small?
Oh, my God.
Why was that on default?
That size could... should not be on default.
Like, that's barely...
Subtitles for ads.
Alright, I put... I put this down louder.
One of those $25 gift certificates.
How is... That should not be default.
Let me get my second... Sorry.
My above average subtitles.
I need to stop my pay.
I love that enthusiasm.
So, anyway, this will be a piece of cake.
Yeah, I didn't even send it anything.
It was default small, but that should not be on default.
It might as well just turn it off.
As for his contract, everything he's been working on for us is now legally ours.
So, we're sending you in to get it.
Our motion sensors indicate that someone is still inside the building, moving around.
Although the signal is a bit erratic.
Oh, we're going to the factory.
Wait, this is like...
Poppy's playtime.
We'll follow up with more instructions soon.
For now, just follow these directions and find your way into that building.
Oh, I hate you.
She's... I hate you.
Amazing.
Thanks for being a part of the Fazbear team.
Yay!
Secrets of the Mimic.
The Legally Distinct Factory.
Wait, you're right.
Why am I driving in between...
Oh, I'm a fucking shitty driver.
Why am I driving in between the lanes?
Hor, hor, hor, hor, hor, hor, hor, hor, hor.
You guys don't remember the lore?
Not Five Nights though, but like, my lore.
I once...
For Five Nights at Freddy's.
My first play, the first Five Nights at Freddy's.
My video got demonetized.
Because I said...
Hor, hor, hor, hor, hor.
Too many times.
And then the game thought I was saying whore.
So I got...
I got demonetized for language.
Just cuz the game thought I was saying whore on repeat.
So I'm trying not to do that this time.
I think it was for Into the Pits.
No, it was.
Never mind.
It was for Into the Pits.
Okay, let's fix the controls.
Apply.
Alright.
So I'm trying not to sing it too much this time.
I sang it too many times for that game.
What was it?
Was it graphics?
The fuck it is?
Oh, FPS cap.
60 only?
Really?
If I'm gonna die, I wanna see it at 140 frames at least.
I wanna see my death in as many frames as possible.
Wow.
Let's see.
Where was this?
Is it an audio?
Oh, there we go.
Why is it on small default?
Sorry.
I'm not compensating.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
I keep doing option because my sensitivity is so low.
Okay.
I mean, it's so high.
I'll do a 20.
Ddustino, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You didn't stream on my birthday, so here's the late super chat.
Have fun with the mimic.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Happy birthday to you.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
Your name was a little difficult for me.
Ddustino.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah!
Sorry.
I was like...
It was like the...
I was meaning to make sure I said it correctly.
Oh, grab.
Alright.
It's so low.
Okay.
I'll fix that.
That data diver is your master.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
I got age restricted.
I got age restri...
That's even worse than demonetization.
They age restricted my VOD.
Because I said whore too many times.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'll fix the...
Well, everything's on high already, so...
I'll boost the volume up.
That's even worse than demonetization.
Okay.
I'll turn down the sound effects then, too.
So then the voice can go up.
I'm constantly testing the waters.
Yeah.
Alright.
Open sesame.
Hello!
I'm here at five nights at MCM.
Oh, this does remind me of Poppy Plain.
Is temporarily closed.
For all deliveries and work inquiries, the client and deliveries entrance is located around the side of the building.
Can't be that bad.
Hello.
Someone's been littering.
What else is over here?
Pretend it down.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
See you at Offcat.
See you guys at Offcat.
I'll be there on Saturday and Sunday.
That's not the side entrance, but there might be free stuff here.
Wait, no, no.
These are Freddy.
Excuse me?
I am playing the five nights at Freddy's game.
Where is my Freddy?
Why is there a playground next to the factory?
Who brings their children here?
After how many fucking incidents someone keeps bringing their children?
Who's this?
Pardon our mess.
Who are these fucking imposters?
I would never...
If I work at something related to, like, Five Nights at Freddy's, I would never bring my child here.
Apparently, there's been, like, quote-unquote, accidents at every, like, Freddy location.
At that point, like, I would never bring my children anywhere near five, like, Freddy's.
Unless I have life...
Unless I get life insurance from my child.
Entertainment and carnival game technologies.
Whoa.
Come in and see what Murray's can do for your carnival, amusement park, midway, or fun fair.
Murray's?
Five Nights at Murray's?
This wide tour will show you just what I'm capable of.
Get ready to be amazed.
Don't forget, every one of my creations are available for purchase or lease.
Be yourself.
Whoa.
This relates to the book series?
Who fucking reads?
What?
Oh, is that Mr. Helpful?
You're not Fred...
Not my Freddy.
Hashtag.
There's so much to be done.
You want to be here to stay.
It's a one of the kind...
Please stop saying...
...fantasy workshop...
...where you'll quite...
...simply be amazed.
Oh!
Oh my god, there's more of you?
Oh, there's a pig.
And there's a crocodile.
Oh my god, where did this guy come from?
This is helpful.
Where's Mrs. Freddy?
Wait, this is better than Freddy.
There's a woman version.
This is my worst nightmare, actually.
If I was a child here, I would fucking cry.
I would cry and just look at the guy.
I did that for...
...um...
...it's a small world.
...a world of weights.
Now it's time to explore.
Step right up.
Don't be scared.
Yeah, it's not...
I'm just seeing this every day at work.
You have to watch this every single day.
Before you clock in, you have to...
It's like...
CEO wants you to watch this every day before you go to work.
What a...
...fucking nightmare.
Mirror.
Wait, there was like...
Oh, here it is.
Light cream.
Time for my daily death anthem.
Alright.
I can go to this door.
I know.
You would cry even now.
Sorry, Stigula Super Chat.
Thank you.
Alright, so I have heard that there is performance issues with this game.
And I could feel it.
So maybe...
Oh my god, I'm on media?
We don't need reflections.
We...
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, hey.
Hey, there's Freddy.
Red Bear's family diner.
There we go.
That's the only time we'll ever see Freddy.
Imagine.
I don't think I have this.
Is a square a diamond?
If...
If I rotate that square a little bit.
Oh.
Mail time.
What's in my mail?
How do I check my mail?
No mail?
Huh?
Oh my god.
I have no fans.
I have no friends or family.
I'm alone.
Jesus Christ.
That shit is fucking scary.
Holy...
I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
Hello?
Oh my god.
How does this bring children joy?
I...
How does that bring kids joy?
Oh.
Oh, I hate this.
I don't understand how that can ever give you joy.
Alright.
Generator time.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
Hello?
You're there.
Pick up.
Hello, hello?
This is my purple guy?
Sorry, my blue guy?
In Five Nights at Murray's?
Recover the Fazbear property.
Mr. Helpful.
Where am I?
Okay, I'm at the security office now.
Oh shit, what year is this?
Here, I finally found the missing...
Pieces of this stupid power device.
Just got to head over there and turn the power on.
I'll check on it soon.
Okay.
Run this.
What the fuck?
I'll go to my bed.
Sure.
Never again?
Why?
Okay, please.
Give me a sec.
I'm playing a video game.
19...
Is this the...
This is the Bite of 87!
Apparently, I read that...
That Bite of 87 was not even important at all.
Look at the actual lore of FNAF.
That, like, blue...
That, like, changed everything for me.
Dear Moon, can you bring back the sun?
Open closet?
Hello?
Is there anybody in the closet?
You hear the gnashing of teeth?
Am I alive?
The thing pulls you to that moon.
Who screams back to bed!
Everything fades to black.
Oh, it's like a mini FNAF game.
Give me a sec.
I'm playing a video game.
I run parachute.ex.
Alright.
Hello?
Yes?
You mean, there's more than one bite?
Who the fuck keeps...
Who the fuck keeps going to Five Nights at Freddy's?
Who keeps going to Freddy Fazbear?
This place should be bankrupt.
We have a little bit of an idea as to what it might be.
That happened at Disneyland?
It's over.
How much money does Freddy Fazbear Pizzeria has?
They have real...
Toki, you don't understand.
They have really good pizza.
But you should probably worry about it.
He was working on an endoskeleton...
When fucking Mickey Mouse bites a child's head open?
I do not think Disneyland would live through that.
It would be closed down for like...
Fuck.
Like all Disneyland's would be closed down.
But we'll be working on some ideas on how to neutralize this group under skillset.
But in the meantime, just try to be quiet, careful, and focused on the task at hand.
Alright.
Always being mindful of the fact that this entity could potentially be inside any costume or character that you see.
Alright, take a deep breath and get back in there.
Finish the job.
And that $25 gift certificate is as good as it is.
Oh my god.
$25 gift certificate.
Bro, minimum wage hitting hard right now.
Let's fucking go.
I could use it to get that good fucking pizza you guys keep talking about.
Guys, I can buy two pizzas with that $25 at Freddy Fazbear's Pizzeria.
Uh, Lali, NCG, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Whee!
Okay, so I need basic security, repair, creator, admin, execs.
What's in here?
Oh, I can't do anything here yet.
Can I do anything here?
No.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
That gives me the diamond.
I assume.
$25 before...
You're right.
That's like at least $100.
Rosie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Upgrade, please.
They're starting to bring dinosaurs back.
And we have movies saying that's a bad idea.
Yes, if this happened at Disney, they just rolled with it.
They just sued the parents for negligence.
What am I supposed to do?
What?
Move to high track?
How did I fail?
I...
Okay.
Oh, I'm supposed to go down.
I'm a little stupid.
Okay, I figured it out.
I was confused with what this game was.
If it was a game.
Wait, no.
I was supposed to move to high.
No, I was supposed to make them all...
Okay, never mind.
Okay.
Now I understand what this game is.
I thought...
I thought zero was better than one.
Now I understand what this game is.
Sorry, I was lying before.
But this time, I understand.
I didn't realize that there was...
It says, flip all bits to one.
Yay!
First try.
I'm so...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You can't sue us for letting our dinosaurs eat your child.
You subscribed to Disney Plus...
Four years ago.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What the fuck?
Were these my footprints?
I don't like how he's just standing there.
Oh.
Oh my god.
How does this bring a child joy?
There was something back here.
I remember.
Okay.
I know that there was a door right here.
Hello.
Hello, little...
Hello, little guys.
Big men.
Big guys.
Why would you put this guy here?
Not even...
Part of security.
What is he?
Is this a pleasure?
No, I just...
Turn it down.
Oh, it is a puzzle.
Whoops.
Don't worry.
I didn't break it.
It is a puzzle.
Oh my god.
This is Poppy Playtime.
We're gonna have to take it here?
Okay.
I'm gonna take it here.
But what if I do it here?
Oh my god, the mouse controls for this is a little wonky.
There we go.
That should be it.
Yeah.
My brain is turning.
There you go.
I fixed it.
Yeah.
It's supposed to go over here, right?
Yeah, there you go.
Who the fuck brought this guy here?
Why is he part of security?
Wait, was he over here?
Whoops.
I think it was supposed to be something here.
Oops.
That's who was he looking at him.
It must have been the win.
I was like, why was there scary music?
I'm sorry.
I couldn't help look at him.
Like, I'm like, why is he here?
Why the fuck would I look out the window after?
Okay, all I'm saying, when I finish this puzzle, why would I turn around?
Alright.
I'm pretty sure he's dead.
There's a dead body in there.
You want me to go back in this room?
Yeah, it was the win.
That was quick.
I did it.
Nine of yellow paint.
Exactly.
They smeared the window with yellow paint.
I would have known.
How's it sound so far, sound guy?
But that doesn't mean the idea isn't sound or valuable.
We think that endoskeleton has a lot of potential.
And that's why we want you to retrieve Murray's original schematic for it.
Oh!
And after you find that schematic for us, we can certainly...
I am Disney!
I'm stealing other people's ideas and claiming them as my own.
If that's not incentive enough to find the schematic, then I don't know what is.
Get that schematic.
And with some luck, you can deactivate that endoskeleton and collect it for us as well.
I can just smell that $25 gift certificate, can't you?
Oh my god.
He didn't pattern it.
Goink, it's mine now.
This is five...
It's like Oswald!
You can't get anywhere near it.
We're Oswald-ing!
We just need to find stations to upgrade your data diver until you can gain access.
They're all over the facility.
In fact, there's a station up in the warehouse manager's office.
You should head there next.
And before you go, take a handcrank for the security fence.
What's the handcrank?
Looks like you can get one from the inventory tube system.
Oh, this one.
That's the big machine in the security office.
Should be active now.
Alright.
Wait, was this a 3D printer?
In 1980s?
Oh, wait.
Whoops.
Grab this.
Okay, tools.
I'll make a crank.
3D print my crank!
Nice.
Now, what are you waiting for?
Keep on trucking.
Alright.
Surely nothing bad's gonna happen to me after that scary wind.
Alright, they're right here.
Here we go.
We're cranking.
I feel like these mouse controls are gonna fuck me over.
Whoa!
What?
Guys, do you think he's friendly?
Do you think he's friendly?
Please open the door.
Whoa!
I didn't think he would actually come over!
What's he gonna do?
Open the door?
That's right.
I know you can't open doors.
That's what you...
What are you gonna do?
Watch this.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
Nothing.
Everything.
That's right.
You're coming.
Watch this.
What you gonna do?
You can't open this.
That's right.
Can't even do anything when the door is open.
Come on.
Stupid.
Look at him.
Waddling back.
Alright, nice.
I'm safe.
He's afraid of dwarves.
He's like a vampire.
You gotta like... You gotta let him in.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The mimic behind Doki waiting to kill her while she fails at flipping the zeros on one.
He's too big.
Look at him.
He can't even fit a door.
That's right.
Let me look out the window at you.
Alright.
I got away from the go left side.
Bro.
What do you mean it was close?
I literally stepped... took one step back.
The fuck?
How am I supposed to...
He's just camping me.
What the fuck?
What am I supposed to do?
Bro.
Okay.
He is fucking fast.
As hell.
Oh my god.
That guy is so fucking fast.
Like...
Wait.
Why do I...
Excuse me.
I have a big ass elephant outside my door.
What do I...
Excuse me.
Talk to me.
This is very important information.
Pick up the phone.
Okay.
Alright.
Maybe I taunted him too much.
We have an actual problem.
Hello?
Human resources?
Okay.
I think he's gone now.
I think he's gone?
Okay.
Never mind.
He's just...
Looking at his...
At his friend.
Okay.
Wait.
Maybe I'll hold it.
Hello?
Why did he...
Why did he stop picking up the phone?
Alright.
Maybe I'll go the other way.
Not his problem.
Wait.
What?
What do I...
Do I have to...
Oh my god.
Do I...
Is this stealth?
Is this...
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's stealth.
Wait.
Do you think he'll see me if I'm here?
No, right?
I'm behind some boxes.
He sees me?
No, wait.
He sees me, right?
Hello?
Okay.
I don't know how he didn't get me, but okay.
That's right.
I got a plushie now.
Watch this.
Okay.
Okay, that's...
That was...
Okay.
I...
I didn't think he would go through the door because he didn't go through the other door.
Okay, look.
He didn't go through the other door.
I thought they just don't go through doors.
That's where I interpret it.
Okay, let me...
At least I'm back here.
Alright.
Yay.
Let's see if I have an email.
I met.
What?
Aww.
Still no friends.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I fucking...
I just thought, you know...
You didn't get through the other door.
Maybe...
Maybe it'll also work here.
I'm going through this toy.
You just gonna...
Am I just gonna hold it for forever?
What am I supposed to do with this?
Hello?
There's too many entrances now.
Oh, no.
My worst fear.
Choices.
Okay, I can't go anywhere, though.
And then...
Ta-da!
Okay, I gotta find a password.
And there's lockers.
I don't put it in...
I don't think I can put it in the inventory.
I'm just gonna be holding it forever.
I don't have an inventory.
Marie's Costume Manor.
What's this?
Number 5.
Oh, it's an elevator.
Alright.
I don't have that.
I don't have access to anything.
Salia.
Uh...
Salajah.
Thank you for...
Welcome to the Mayo Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Alright.
Let's go to the elevator.
It's just one floor?
What kind of elevator is this?
I can't put it anywhere.
The elevator is broken.
That doesn't sound good.
Oh.
I don't like that.
Mmm.
Really don't like that.
Come in bigger sizes?
What?
Oh, no free drink.
There's so many doors.
I'm not going in there.
Oh, wait.
Is that safe room?
Oh, thank God.
That's another safe room.
Am I just going to hold this forever?
Okay.
I can grab this.
Helper.
Uh, map.
Where am I?
I'm going to pretend I know how to read this.
Uh, logs.
Hey, everyone.
These mailboxes are everywhere.
If you see something strange, then keep the group informed.
Great idea, Pete.
Mr. Murray hasn't used these mailboxes for so long.
It should be safe.
I'd love to have some place for all of us to talk in private.
I feel like the boss man is listening to us all the time.
Alright.
Apparently, I could...
put this in here?
How do I put that in here?
Okay.
Let me open this.
Oh, downloading.
Oh!
Okay.
Repair permission.
What am I repairing?
Oh, it's this.
Uh...
Am I doing it?
I don't think I'm doing it.
I'm doing it.
Uhhh...
Okay.
Oh no, not puzzles.
Not puzzles.
Oh my god, not puzzles.
Oh no!
Okay, I have to do it again.
Oh fuck, I have to do all of this again.
No!
Alright, I got this.
Also, I know I asked Sound Guy what he thought about the sound, but then like, I didn't read his answer.
I know, I'm trying to... I'm using my brain as best as I could.
It's not that good, but like, at least I'm trying... Oh fuck!
Oh fuck!
Whoops.
Okay, it's fine.
Okay, I figured it out.
Fuck!
I can't...
Why did I put it on...
Sorry, that was my bad.
I can't...
There we go, there we go.
I keep turning them into zeros instead of ones.
Because I feel like, haha, zero is better, because it's infinite.
You know when you're like, you can't divide by zero?
I keep thinking I should put in zero.
There we go.
Less is more!
Okay, now I...
I don't know what I repaired though.
Oh, did I turn this in?
Yeah?
Oh, nice.
Where did I put this?
Oh, here!
Alright, in you go.
I'll put you in here too.
My little collectible.
Is that it?
What...
What else can I get from here?
Oh yeah, it is my collectible.
Okay.
That's why I un-3D printed my collectible.
I don't even know what I repaired.
Guys, do I go into the deep, dark hole filled with animatronics?
Or do I just use my crank?
Oh, I have to make another crank.
Forgot the elephant man took my crank.
Oh.
I just looked at it.
I was like...
Where...
Where did it go?
Alright.
Oh!
It's a storage machine!
It's not a 3D printer.
I was like...
Where crank?
Alright.
Into the hole I go.
Where every hole there is a goal.
Hello?
Let's crank this...
Cranky box.
Is that the mimic?
Hello?
I don't think I will.
What the?
What's over here though?
Oh, it's just nothing.
She's gonna...
Try and kill me, isn't she?
Is that the mimic of 39?
That won't come back to fucking kill me.
Oh!
Let's play!
Red bear's family diner.
She has...
I mean...
Very long hands.
Ready to execute.
I don't even hear that.
Oh.
These are all the other animatronics that's gonna fucking kill me.
Who's in here?
Hello?
Are you a good guy?
What?
I don't have any mail.
Do you need a snappy delivery?
That's why I don't have mail.
I told you guys I have friends.
It's just that guy keeps fucking up my deliveries.
I told you.
Look, see?
He's shredding all my mail.
Guys, I swear to God I...
Crank, Crank, Crank, Crank, Crank, Crank!
Crank!
Oh my god!
How do I...?
Holy...
Is he...?
What?!
He's getting closer?!
Oh, okay.
Okay, it's not me.
He's it, not me.
Oh!
Did you guys notice that I started cranking it faster?
Why did she throw it up?
I was just like leisurely cranking it.
And then I was Mach 7.
What?
Was she above me?
No, we're fine.
Okay, I was gonna...
Because I was gonna tab up and look at what sound guys said.
Oh, they didn't say anything about the sound, so that means we're good to go.
I don't know, I heard a strange noise.
And like all horror movie characters, we don't walk away.
We walk towards the scary sound.
So we can pad the time.
Fine, she's not gonna get me.
I can leisurely enjoy my surroundings.
She's not even chasing me!
Why would I need a run?
I can enjoy my surroundings.
Look at that, I made it.
That easy.
Look at that.
I knew she wouldn't get me.
She has no legs.
The seconds before disaster.
Oh, maybe I have to run now.
Oh, I think this time she definitely is gonna kill me.
I...
Oh, yep!
That looks like run!
Wow!
Did you guys see the text that says, Maybe you should run?
Alright.
Oh!
No!
I thought I could run backwards.
I...
I didn't realize you can't run backwards.
I just wanted to look at it.
Now I know.
Whoa.
Okay, there we go.
It's fixed.
This is like, whoa.
Alright.
Oh, it's this way!
I was waiting for the door to the screen!
Okay, here we go.
Oh, my God.
The friends!
Jackie!
Give me back my friends!
Oh!
Okay, don't look back!
Don't look back!
Come back, Toki!
You made the mistake once!
Don't make the mistake again!
Okay.
You should be fine now.
There we go.
Wait, I don't ask.
I don't ask too.
She gonna open the door for me?
Whoa!
I thought she was gonna...
I was like, oh, she's gonna open the door for me, right?
I...
Okay!
I assumed that the door was gonna open.
She was gonna do something and the door would just open.
Which way is it?
Oh, this part takes up so many frames.
It's like, Jackie, open the door!
There's a crank?
Okay, I got this.
I figured it out.
Yeah, I was gonna be like, can you open this door for me?
So we can keep doing this, like, little cat and mouse chase?
That you're trying to choose...
I don't know.
I just thought it was a way of flirting.
The fuck is this crank that I missed?
Alright.
Jackie, I didn't consent to our birthday, huh?
Cause it's not my birthday yet!
And where the fuck is this crank?
Oh, there it is!
Okay, I found it.
It's only me for thinking that she would be nice enough to open the door for me.
You know?
Doesn't she wanna keep playing tag?
Okay, there's no missing cranks this time.
Oh!
Okay.
Wait, I can't...
Oh my god!
I jumped!
My thighs are too thick to jump, apparently!
And it's...
It's made of sticks!
Why can't I jump?!
Okay.
Look, she was saying happy birthday.
I had to let her say happy birthday.
Okay, now I see the crank.
There we go.
Yeah, that's Becky right!
Ah!
I thought she was dead!
How could she still kill me?!
It's just a head!
It's just...
Okay.
Anyway.
Yeah, that's Becky right!
Can't do shit now!
No!
Oh gosh, it's start cranking.
I need to stop gloating and start cranking!
She's always watching!
I thought she was gonna...
It was just the head!
How was she able to grab me?!
Okay.
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat!
Alright, here we go!
I might have celebrated too soon, guys!
Oh, hello?
What the fuck?!
Okay.
Yay!
I got an achievement for killing Jackie!
Oh!
It was all just a scary dream!
Please respond!
Over!
Hey, there's like...
Crazy murder bots going around!
Hello?
Oh!
Glad to see you made it here without any complications whatsoever!
So we did some digging to learn more about that bothersome endoskeleton that keeps relentlessly pursuing you!
I don't think they're...
From what we can tell, it was designed to keep Murray's son entertained while Murray worked.
It would mimic the actions of those around it.
At some point...
The mimic!
Title drop!
The details of which are a little fuzzy.
This mimic endoskeleton then copied that violent behavior.
Oh, he was a special boy!
We came up with some great ideas on how you protect yourself.
Unfortunately, we came up with some great ideas on how to protect yourself.
What happened to him?
So, it seems that maybe distraction and avoidance are your best tools.
As a direct confrontation...
Can I have a gun?
You like that!
I like that.
Oh...
...and I'm sure they would tell you that themselves, if they hadn't died from blood loss.
We expect you'll succeed where they failed.
One out of three Fazbear employees has confidence in you, so go get them, Tiger.
Wait, I don't like the size.
I found the location of another upgrade station in the showrooms.
You can get there if you head back through the welcome show.
That's the room where you entered the building.
Wait, one out of three?
Check the monitor.
I'm sending you a camera feed.
Go there.
Oh.
Over and out.
I feel like...
Can you send me a gun?
I like a shotgun, please.
All right.
Maps.
Wait, how is he sending me a camera feed?
Like, where is the camera feed?
It's in here?
No.
What the fuck is the TV?
Oh!
Okay.
That's...
Sorry.
Two, six.
Is that the password?
The one angle I didn't look at.
Two, six, two.
All right, gamers don't look up, guys.
Two, six, two, nine.
Four.
Two, six, two, nine, four.
That it?
Two, six, two, nine, four?
Wait, what is that?
Oh, that's where I have to go.
Two, six, two, nine, four.
Okay.
Yeah.
Who's...
All right, remember that.
Two, six, two, nine, four, guys.
I'm gonna make sure it's correct.
Two, six.
I'm too lazy for that.
I trust you guys.
I think the elephant's gone.
Right?
He's not gone, is he?
He's always here watching me.
Oh, he's here.
I can hear him.
He's never gone.
That's the secret.
He's always here watching me.
Good job.
You can reach the lobby from here.
Where?
The lobby doors have been locked by some showtime run mirrors, whatever that means.
Look for a control station.
You should be able to get those doors to open by restarting the welcome show program.
What the fuck is that?
Here?
Oh, it must be here.
There's a lever.
There's a way.
Hello?
Oh, that's an upgrade.
Welcome show update.
We need to update the swing B.
He's shorting out.
Oh, we should reset it.
Alright, let's reset everything.
So we can access the show tab.
Do I have this?
I do.
It's over here.
What do I do here?
What the fuck?
What does this do?
What?
Who said that?
Is that the one...
The millions of children that died at Five Nights at Murray's?
Who said that?
Oh, at the crouch?
Wait, is that the...
Is that the mimic?
Oh yeah, because he mimics the child.
Oh, there is a place.
Who's crying?
Hello?
Are you in here?
There's a child crying.
In my game.
I don't like that.
Oh.
I'll go back.
Whenever there's a child crying, that's never a good thing.
I'll head back downstairs.
Hello?
Alright.
I feel like I just might have missed something.
What's up with the crying child?
Oh.
It's hiding time.
It's time to play Alien Isolation.
I'll bust in nowhere.
Okay.
Oh, it's hide and seek.
Oh, one of these.
Oh.
They
just all go la la la.
I don't like this.
I don't like this, Harry.
Hello, emergency.
This is a big emergency.
Oh, hey!
What was the password again, guys?
I already forgot.
Two.
Six.
Nine.
Oh, that's not the right area.
I hate this area.
Do I have this?
I do.
I don't.
I'm not ready.
I'm not.
I don't want to play hide-and-seek.
I'm tired of this, Grandpa.
Where the fuck do I go?
That's too bad.
There's a door that I need to go?
Oh, is it that door?
Oh, it's that door.
Found the door.
Found it.
What's this?
That's a safe door.
Okay, nothing in here.
Hello?
Oh, it's safe.
That means I'm in a safe area.
Uh...
Where am I?
I'm in the welcome lobby.
There's nothing new.
Oh.
What's this?
Can you help me, Mr. Help... Mrs. Helpful?
Error.
This elevator is out of service.
Which one?
This one?
Thank you for your patience.
Thanks.
Oh, that was very helpful, Mrs. Helpful.
Enjoy a short ride on this reliably safe elevator to access the MCM showrooms.
That it?
Oh, that wasn't very helpful at all, Mrs. Helpful.
Did she make that noise?
Alright, what's...
What's in here?
Let me...
Oh, my God.
Please!
Why am I not strong enough?
My noodle arms.
My noodle arms are just...
It's so noodle-y.
Oh, yeah, there's a little guy here.
I know, it's hard.
Hello?
Hi.
I'm Paul.
What are you doing?
Is he cleaning?
Oh, he's like a little clean bot.
I need to train more.
Holy shit.
Okay, let me lower the graphics for this.
Jesus.
I'm a...
Guys, I'm a 40-80.
Like, I don't understand.
Oh, my God.
How much more do I have to lower the graphics?
Yeah, I need a training montage.
Okay, what do I lower?
Guys, we gotta pick our poison.
The 49...
Guys, you're right.
I should get a 50-80 to play the new FNAF game.
Shadows?
You're right.
We don't need shadows.
I can pet him?
Can I?
Do I pet him?
Oh, I can!
Oh, who's a good boy?
You are.
All right.
If I want to get rid of this...
Ah!
Never mind, give up.
Fuck this.
Let this elevator be broken.
Wait, no, I do have to fix it.
No, I have to fix it.
Press this button.
No, this doesn't let me press anything.
Miss Helper, I need help.
Oh!
I can upgrade.
This elevator is out of service.
Okay, I need more help than that.
Thank you for your patience.
Wait, what is this Miss Helper?
Security...
You help me now?
Security personnel, please help with client relations until the elevator remains...
All right.
I am security.
Attention.
Elevator maintenance is required.
Referred to the repair cassette for instructions.
But where's the repair cassette?
The repair cassette is conveniently located on the second floor balcony.
All right, that's convenient.
Please enter the following code to retrieve the repair cassette.
Zero, one, five, eight.
Okay.
All right.
Zero, one, five, eight.
Still cleaning.
All right.
This is where I die.
Oh.
Okay.
Zero, one, five.
True.
Oh my god.
He's so fast.
Ha ha ha.
Stupid.
That's right.
Where did I go?
No object permanence for you.
Ha ha ha ha.
He doesn't know I'm in the locket.
Ha ha ha.
Fast but stupid.
That's right, dumb dog.
All right.
Let's just wait.
He doesn't have object permanence.
That's right.
His one weakness.
You think he's up the stairs now?
Is that upstairs?
That's upstairs, right?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Oh, wait.
It takes him forever to go up the stairs.
Oh.
Ha ha ha.
He's like, wait.
Where did he go?
Ha ha ha.
All right.
I need him to go up the stairs again.
I like how he's like, scurries downstairs.
Ha ha ha.
I like it.
He is wandering.
Guys, I'm not gonna...
This dog is un-pet-able, guys.
If I pet him, he's gonna fucking bite my head off.
All right.
Open sesame.
Okay, there you go.
Now where do I put this?
Where do I put a tape?
Where do you put the tape?
I have the tape.
Attention.
Elevator maintenance is required.
Refer to the repair cassette for instructions.
Machine?
Which machine?
The repair cassette is conveniently located...
Is it this?
Oh, oh, that's a cassette player?
Oh, I thought it was like a gotcha machine.
Wait.
Ha ha ha.
Okay, it looked like a gotcha.
And grab the side walls until repairs are finished.
Please follow these simple instructions to reset the elevator.
First, open the repairmatic box.
Oh, it may already be open.
But if it isn't, then do that.
Let's go gathering.
Next, turn the power off.
Okay.
Once the elevator is off, remove any obstructions from the exposed machinery.
Oh!
It would also be a good time to ask the passenger...
Oh my god, thank god.
My noodle dimes, I did it.
Rotate the hand crank clockwise to raise the elevator.
What do I...
What do I get this guy out of...
Oh, maybe I'll put him in the storage.
Wait, what?
Instructions unclear.
What do I do with this?
I...
I can't.
What do I...
How do I...
Oh, okay, I dropped it.
Oh, oh, right click is dropped.
I was like, am I gonna hold this forever?
Okay.
Open it.
She'll see.
Oh, there's a note here.
If the elevator is out of alignment, adjust the thing that balances it.
That's what it says.
Is there an alignment?
There's a line.
Hold up.
I almost forgot.
Make sure...
Oh, I knew it.
I knew it.
Where the fuck is the emergency...
Oh, emergency brake.
Here it is.
Yeah.
To re-align the elevator, use the sliders to re-balance the load-weight alignment.
Doohickey.
And please, bear in mind, if anything does go wrong, we want you to know that it's not your fault.
It's another one of life's speed bumps.
I'll be dead.
Being dead is not a speed bump.
Great.
Now that I assume you are done with the alignment, use the diagnosis and repair function.
Input the following code using the buttons.
One, two, three...
I saw...
I was like, wait, what?
You are now safe to get under the elevator.
What?
Oh, there's an...
To realign the elevator.
What the buttons are?
Oh!
I didn't look down!
I...
Gators don't look down as well.
If anything does go wrong, we want you to know that it's, it's not your fault.
Okay, I got so confused.
I was like, where the button is these?
Okay.
Four...
Great.
Now that I assume you are done with the alignment, use the diagnosis...
She said it wasn't my fault, guys!
Then put the following code using the buttons.
One...
Oh, it's different.
Four...
Two...
One...
Three...
Four...
Two...
Wait, what was the last one I didn't press?
Three.
There we go.
Now, disengage the emergency brake and back out carefully.
Alright.
This is different, cause...
The first one was four.
Alright.
Got you.
Turn on the power, and you are done.
Yay!
I did it!
I'm so smart!
I feel so smart!
First try!
Alright, this way.
I did it, guys!
No death so far, everyone.
Not a singular death.
Eh?
There can't be any monsters here.
I can't even run.
I can enjoy my surroundings.
What's down here?
Oh.
Hello?
Oh, that's where the clean bot is.
Oh, I can crank.
Oh, and another collectible!
Yay!
What's that?
Chica's party world!
Oh my god, I can sell this on eBay.
Oh wait.
I gotta check if I get mail.
Any mail?
Oh.
So, no friends, I guess.
Okay.
Grab this.
So I can...
So I can store my collectible.
Oh!
Gotta make sure that's safe.
And then...
Grab my letter...
Oh.
Wait.
What?
Oh, is this for collectible?
Oh, I wasn't even supposed to be here.
Oh.
That was just for the collectible.
Alright.
I guess I go back up.
Wait.
Actually...
I want...
Sure, I don't...
Maybe I downloaded mail here.
Wait, no.
That's the map.
I hope this message reaches someone.
There's something outside.
I have no idea what it wants.
I can still hear Thompson's screams.
I can't sign up for this.
Oh, I fixed the elevator.
You're right.
Oh, outside.
I fixed the elevator outside.
Oh, he's gone.
Yes.
He's not gone.
He's not...
I saw the elephant.
I was like...
Oh, he's not gone.
No shaking in the elevator.
Oh, hey.
Another one of you.
Hello there.
Hey.
Who's a good robot.
You are.
That's right.
You are made clean.
Alright.
This is less scary.
It's just a hallway.
There's Carter Caterpillar.
There.
And on.
There's suits of armor.
Surely they won't come alive to fucking kill me.
Oh, there's another one of you guys.
Hello there.
If I treat you all well, you won't turn evil and try to kill me.
Come on.
Who wants a little pet?
That's right.
Alright.
Let's see what she says for regular people.
Oh, Mr. Helpa.
Welcome to the furry showrooms.
Everything's for sale or lease.
Please inquire within for availability and delivery options.
We're said to announce that the storytime showroom is currently closed, pending mitigation of insurance claims.
Oh, there they.
I bet they were- I bet they were trying to- Trying to feast us for more money.
Rooftop access permissions have been changed to accommodate our creative team.
So they can retard the roof.
If you require rooftop access, upgrade your permissions at the security office located on the second floor of the big top showroom.
That's right.
But I am security, Mr. Helpful.
You should be aware of potential power spikes.
In case of an outage, use the conduit in the big top showroom entrance to reset the system.
I don't like these.
I don't- Oh, I don't like that.
They're just there.
I like it.
They're just standing there, menacingly.
It's in here.
This is my- Oh, this is a safe room.
Nice.
Oh, hey, there's someone- Okay, four?
I remember this, guys.
Four.
It's just four?
Is that it?
Seven.
Four, seven.
What?
Four, seven, eight.
God, it's so slow.
Two.
Four, seven, eight, two.
Oh, four, seven, eight, two.
Cyclone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
So happy that those robots got met by Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Absol!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He thought this would be a horror game, but it's actually an elevator maintenance simulator.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Here we go.
Doing my job.
Fixing elevators.
Oh, that's Mr. Moon!
Hey, does Mr. Moon exist, too?
Can I borrow your voice for a project?
Oh, what for?
I don't even know you.
I'm brand new here.
Let's start again.
I'm Fiona, and you are?
Edwin.
Edwin Murray.
This is my dad's place.
Oh, it's him!
It's the owner.
It's Walt Disney.
Oh, he's the one that made the mimic!
Oh, so the mimic's gonna have the girl's voice.
That's incredible!
What do you call it?
Oh, um... I don't know.
I... I haven't thought of a name yet.
Well, how would you describe it in one word?
I guess I would have to say... Helpful.
Yeah.
At its core, it is helpful.
That's a great name.
And I would be delighted to help.
What kind of voice should I do?
Oh.
What's the voice?
I'll never know what voice she did!
Okay, as soon as I heard that here, like...
As soon as I hear the female voice, I'll be like, It's the mimic.
It's her.
It's the showroom.
Oh, is that... Okay.
That should grab me access.
Oh.
This is helpful?
There's something inside this box.
Wait, do you guys hear that?
It's like breathing.
Something breathing in here.
I...
I don't...
I know you're in here!
I can hear you breathe!
It's not like you're...
Oh my god.
I...
Happy birthday...
To...
You...
It's...
It's the fucking...
Marilyn...
Marilyn Monroe in me.
I swear to god.
I hear the voices!
Oh.
There's a little hole now.
Happy birthday...
Mr. President.
Wait, is that me?
Am I breathing?
Do I just not do cardio?
Oh, it's me, isn't it?
It was me this entire time.
Oh my god.
I just walked like five steps and I didn't do enough cardio.
La la la la.
La la la.
AHHHHH!
Maybe he won't turn around.
Zajan, thank you for the super chat again.
You mean I missed that code!
Oh, there's a TV over there.
Guys, I don't have time to watch the TV.
Okay, he'll turn around.
Who do do do do?
Who do do do?
I can wait.
Guys, I don't have time to watch the T.V.
There's a guy fucking trying to kill me.
He he he he he he.
It's too late.
I gotta be a streamer now.
I gotta do at chat.
What's that over there?
Is there something over there?
Oh my god, guys, at chat!
Wait, what's over here?
Oh, I could go back.
At chat, what's the code?
The breathing is...
Alright.
Guys, I trust you.
At chat!
8... 4... 6... I know it's not boobs!
2... 6... 2... 4... Guys, please.
3... 5... 1... 1... Oh my god.
Okay, it's 4 digits.
3... 4... 6... 9... Oh my god.
I know it's not boobs!
4... 20... 69... Oh my god, he's gonna be here.
6... 6... 5... 83... Please!
I know one of you guys have the... 7... 6... 2... 0...
0... 4... 5... What?
One of these has to be correct.
8... 6... 7... 9... Jesus!
I'm skipping this.
It's a collectible.
That's right.
No collectible for you guys.
You think I care enough?
It's a 3... 0... 0... 0...
1.
Doki, thank you for this.
Thank you.
I know it's a...
I know it isn't 3... 0... 0... 1.
Cause it is 3... 0... 0...
1.
People in chat would say it's 3... 0... 0... 1.
I did not see anyone else.
Right?
3... 0... 0...
1.
Oh, 0... 0... 0... 0... 0... 0... 0... 0... 0... 0... 0... 0... 0... 0... 0... 0... 0...
0...
0 I knew it.
All you achievement hunters, I got you.
I know what you think.
I know how you think.
You know you wanted me to get that collectible.
You're like, no, Doki, I can't sleep if I can't see you get that collectible.
I read your fucking mind and then I turn on this lever.
I don't know what it does, but I turn on any lever I see.
Alright.
I know what you are.
I have no idea what that did.
It did something.
I know you can't live without me getting that collectible.
Alright, here we go.
Now I'm back here.
Hello, everybody.
Oh, I'm back to another safe zone.
Yes.
What did that music play?
Hello?
Oh, I'm back, yeah.
Oh.
Okay, I feel like there might be something here.
Hello?
Wait, I can use the... Wait, what?
What do I do here?
Okay, that's where...
Can I go downstairs?
Can I use this elevator?
Oh, I can.
Oh, the male guy.
Forgot about him.
Is he still back here?
Wait, you're back here?
How did you get back here?
Hello?
Oh.
Why won't you let me through the door?
Are you okay?
I was gonna say he's alive.
Execute.
Do you need a snappy delivery?
Wait, why can't that go through?
I deliver in a snap.
That can't be, right?
Quick and snap, snap, snappy.
Do you need a snappy delivery?
Yeah, there's an invisible box here.
Mail call.
Oh, the game bugged?
I was like, why... I was like, why is there an invisible wall?
It's like, who the fuck is blocking me?
The force of God?
Oh, he's supposed to be dead?
He came back to life.
Not in Doki's game.
You can never kill the mailman.
What if I just do this?
Do you need a snappy delivery?
Does it break the game even more?
Yeah, I was gonna say!
I didn't even come back!
It's ghost robot.
It's like the ghost shit.
Can I just go back down then?
Oh, do not deuce the elevator?
I can't...
I can't go into the hole!
Hey, what do I do?
Oh, Jackie's room.
Okay.
Oh, that's Jackie's room.
Hello, I'm back here.
Yeah.
Again?
Door locked doors?
Oh, not vent.
Oh!
Yeah, I was gonna say, didn't I just do this?
Why do I have to go back here?
Oh, I'm being one guide.
Typical Doki.
Being one guide by several guys.
Oh, this door.
Oh!
Wait, no.
I was here.
This is the...
Happy birthday, miss...
Wait, this one.
Wait, this is new.
Yeah, one squad.
Yeah, I'm back.
Wait, no.
I'm not back.
Um...
Wait, no.
I'm not back.
I gotta go back.
Didn't I come from here?
Well, I'm lost.
Yeah, I guess she was like...
Happy birthday, Mr. President.
Oh, the big door showroom!
Oh!
JK.
I was on the right track.
Guys, I'm so confused.
There's too many stairs.
There's too many choices.
Too many doors!
Oh, I don't like this clown.
That's not a sexy clown.
Oh, another puzzle.
Okay, I know how to do puzzles, though.
Do you, Doki?
Yes, guys.
I know.
God.
These controls, though.
Fucking sucks.
For the puzzles.
Yeah.
Like that.
And then...
I don't like these controls, though.
For the puzzles.
It doesn't bring me joy.
Like that.
And then...
Okay.
That doesn't work.
Wait.
It's timed?
Okay.
Now I know.
Now I know it's time.
Guys, the answer is not boobs.
I'm very confident in that.
Guys, I know for a fact...
That the answer is not boobs.
Oh, my God.
I hate...
Oh, I hate these controls.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Okay.
No!
Please!
I'm gonna...
You're right.
It's boobs.
Not a boob.
I hate this.
I hate this on mouse and keyboard.
Oh, my God.
Please!
I did it.
Okay.
There we go.
I need help.
Alright.
We did it.
Do your thing.
I'm just gonna wait.
Actually, no.
Fuck it.
I'm too lazy.
I'm gonna wait it out.
Oh!
Yeah!
Experience the latest in carnival and midway game technologies.
You're like...
A man.
Test your skills.
Test your luck.
Win a prize or make a buck.
Alright.
Give me a ticket, please.
Ticket, please.
If you'd like to license that jingle, inquire within the rates.
Thank you.
Here's my ticket.
Hello!
Yeah!
Oh.
Whoever designed this robot definitely really hated children.
You've come to the big-time showroom!
Let us spend our money on that game.
Tickets, please.
Where's my...
I enjoy time with my family.
Oh.
So many, right?
Which game will I play first?
Um...
I'll play this game.
Step right up and smack a clown!
It can't be that hard.
Ready, set...
Where did the clown come from?
Oh!
It's just literally...
It's just smacking the teeth.
I know how to do that.
Boom!
Oh, I already lost.
Okay, there's fall off damage!
Oh wait, there's more than...
Okay, nice.
I just aim for the nose?
Oh, wait!
I thought I...
Alright, let's try.
I got this.
I thought I limited ammo.
But I don't.
Jeez.
How much do I have to get?
Oh, this is so easy.
Boom!
Give me another one!
I already won!
That's fucking right!
Ba-da-da-dum, ba-da-da-dum, ba-na-da-dum.
So easy!
That's fucking right!
Give me my tickets!
Oh, oh.
Six, two, uh, oh,
six, six.
This is better than ice cream.
This is better than ice cream... 6, 2, 5... wait, what's that over there?
Is that 7?
I'm feeling evil, man, now.
I am having so much fun.
I don't know, I thought he would cover me!
I was like, oh, he's right in front of me.
Can't get me now.
Tickets, please.
He was right in front of me!
Oh, it's new now.
6, 4, 9, 2, okay.
Tickets, please.
Alright.
6, 4, 9, 2.
Where do I go, though?
I have to go to that locker.
Okay, I gotta head to that one locker over there.
Alright, guys, remember this.
6, 4, 9, 2.
Tickets, please.
Please.
No, he doesn't see me.
I'm gonna make it, wait for him to turn around first.
Guys, it can't be boobs!
Oh, there's a 1.
Wait, what's the number?
Oh my god.
I think B...
Oh!
Whoops.
I was gonna say, this area kills frames.
Oh my god.
Oh no, wait.
Does he know?
Oh, he knows.
I got so overwhelmed looking at this.
I'm sorry.
I saw this and I was like, what the fuck am I looking at?
I got so overwhelmed.
I saw this.
I was like, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's...
Hello.
I have the ticket.
He's slowly crawling towards me.
What do I do?
Oh my god, he's just...
I need to know.
I need to know how much data this game is taking me.
I...
I need to know.
I'm curious.
I put up my time.
I need to know how much this game is...
Why...
Why it's sucking up so much resources.
Zero, three, eight.
I enjoy time with my family.
Zero, eight, nine, five, four.
Pickets, please.
Oh my god.
My CPU goes to a hundred.
It's not even GPU.
It's my CPU.
It is at a hundred.
Holy shit.
This game takes 62% of my CPU.
It's at full capacity.
Oh my...
Wait, what do you mean by it?
It's the encoder.
Oh my god.
Alright, it's time to shoot gun.
It hungers for more.
Start.
QQ.
Oh my god.
Why is the gun sensor so high when I have the gun?
It's really fucking high.
I wish I was joking.
Oh my god.
I moved like one inch and it's like across the screen.
Alright, nice.
Okay, that has to be the...
Okay, the high score is 25.
Guys, I think I beat the high score.
Yeah.
Oh.
It's tickets time.
It's ticket time.
Tickets, please.
Oh my god.
What if I play this game yet?
If I play this game at... Alright, it's time to choose.
Pick our poison.
It's time to pick another one.
It's time to pick one more in the lower.
A global low.
Anti-Alias?
Alright.
There we go.
Time to pick another poison.
Okay, let's do...
Oh, I forgot to... Oh, wait.
Okay, wait.
I need to do audio first.
Music.
I'll put music down.
Okay, apparently I forgot to click apply for graphics.
Graphics.
Low.
Shadow.
There we go.
Apply.
I don't know if it'll fix anything, but maybe I won't be at 100.
Oh, nope.
Never mind.
Okay.
I want to pay money to play this game.
Alright, here we go.
It's literally only a certain area.
No, this game is not very optimized.
I read in the... I read in the reviews that you need a really, really tanky PC to play this game because it's not very well optimized.
The reviews were saying that.
They were like...
Oh, yeah.
No.
Like...
I have like a 4d9 and I can't even run this game.
What do you mean by it's the encoder?
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh.
Because I don't know PC talk.
Oh my god, I can't- fucking- Oh!
Okay, clearly that's not- Oh my god, I still had this guy on.
Oh my god, please.
That's it.
Just explain that, like, I don't know what PC is.
We did it.
Wait, there's a prize?
Where's the prizes?
I want my prizes.
I got a free spin?
Where?
Get this gun out of here.
Oh, is OBS setting eating my CPU?
Oh, it's because I'm in, like, 1440p.
I need the new encoder on OBS?
What do you mean?
Where's the free spin?
How do I spin the wheel?
Where's the wheel?
A gun.
Oh, it's in the back room?
Oh!
I can't get enough of...
Ah!
I want prizes!
Alright.
What did I get?
Oh, I got another prize.
Oh, 15% discount?
Yeah.
We love prizes!
Spin, spin, spin, spin!
Wee!
Spin, spin, spin!
A lifetime supply of candy?!
What are the odds?
Where is it?
Hello?
Where's my...
Where is it?
I want my lifetime supply of candy!
Oh my god.
The...
I can't believe he lied at me.
Take my wallet!
Oh, I have another gun.
Step right up and...
But what if I can have two guns?
Shoot the targets to win a spin!
Ready!
Set!
Oh, it's a nice shooting game.
Okay, there is not enough variety.
The same team as the last one!
Okay.
Easy.
I think I already passed.
I think I already succeeded this level.
Wait, the sensitivity for this one is not as bad this time.
Check this, please.
Oh yeah, I'm already, like, way ahead.
Yay!
Okay, we gotta stop here.
Nice.
We have a winner!
Yay!
Tickets, please.
And what did you win?
Oh, did I win?
A free spin on the prize wheel!
Yay!
And what a prize wheel to redeem your free spin!
Tickets, please.
What if I shoot it?
Do I win?
No, I can't win!
I can't win!
No!
No...
You're stupid!
I'm sorry!
No!
What is he looking at?
He's over there.
Tickets, please.
That's right.
I'm never sorry.
I'll do it again.
Alright.
Here we go again.
Okay.
How do I do it like this?
Then... Oh, that doesn't work.
Oh, that doesn't work.
Okay.
And then... There we go.
Yeah!
That's fucking right!
I solved the puzzle!
What you gonna do now?
Slowly walk towards me?
Ha ha ha!
Tickets, please.
Four, three, five, eight.
What are these numbers?
Alright.
10.
Wheel of prizes.
Spin, wheel, spin.
A mystery puzzle.
Just try again and expect a different result.
I don't know.
I said, let's have supply pie!
What the fuck is my pie?!
I have one more spin!
One more spin!
That's right!
A grand prize!
A door!
Home of the original.
Can you know that?
Oh my god, guys!
I got...
What I've always wanted!
A fucking door!
Oh, hey!
Look!
That's it!
Most valued customer!
That just means I spend the most money!
Oh, he's gone!
Wait, what happened to him?
How would I get my ticket now?!
Sorry!
Hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor!
That's what I meant!
Uh, crown...
Where's the crown guy?
One...
Where's the cowboy?
Is that cowboy?
Wait...
Is that a cowboy hat?
No, that's a...
Farm hat!
One, five...
Nine...
Four.
One, five, nine, four.
One...
Five...
Nine...
Four...
Wait, what?
Another cowboy hat?
Is that missing?
Is that a cowboy hat?
Does it look like a cowboy hat?
Zero.
One, zero, nine, four.
One...
Zero...
Nine...
Four.
There you go.
Oh, that wasn't even a cowboy hat!
I know I have a lot more to this game because I have three other symbols that I haven't unlocked yet.
So...
I know.
I have a long way to go.
Oh, I got my...
No, two more symbols I haven't locked yet.
Let's go!
My trophy!
Oh!
No!
My trophy!
I got to absorb with the...
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Guys, I...
I did it again.
Alright, I fixed it.
There we go.
Yeah!
I actually forgot any of the rooms that require this upgrade.
Can I go back for it?
Because I need my trophy.
I need to know that I did a good job.
I need validation.
Oh, yeah.
Got my trophy.
Most value customer.
Because I have a credit card.
Where did I put this?
Where is Rufax this?
Oh, there it is.
I knew there had to be.
Whoop!
Ed, I hope this message reaches you as soon as you get a break.
I have to go help the Fall Fest crew.
Just for a few days until the installation is finished.
It's hard to explain.
I just have this terrible feeling like I need to be there so nothing goes wrong.
Just in case.
Trisha will babysit David while I'm gone.
I love you both, and I'll be back next week.
Hmm.
And she never came back.
Wait, I have to get the... my gun?
Okay, but do I... I already got the achievement where I shot somebody with a gun.
Alright.
Is that a collectible?
Wait, is a gun a collectible?
Yeah, I'll go back downstairs.
Wait.
Where did I leave my gun?
Guys, I don't think I can get my gun back.
Oh!
Wait, no, that's not my... yeah, guys.
Wait, did I drop my gun?
I don't remember.
I remember I threw my gun.
Can't see.
So dark.
Okay, I think it... it disappeared.
I think it despawned.
I'm pretty sure the gun despawned.
Too late.
It's gone forever.
Whatever.
No more gun.
I wanna make sure I got...
Oh wait, there's another TV.
What's on this TV?
Anything important?
Nope.
Just a TV.
Alright.
This is time to go to the roof.
Unlock roof.
Hello?
Anybody here?
Ooh.
Watch out for exposed wiring.
Okay, why don't you just fix the wiring?
Hello?
Wait, it's snowing now.
Okay, why don't they just fix it instead of giving me a fucking sign to be like, Watch out!
We're not gonna fix it, but watch out!
If you have time to write me a be careful sign, you have time to fix this.
Alright, do you guys spamming really hard?
I might spam them out if they're spamming too much.
Oh hey, tickets please.
Hi.
I don't have my ticket, I'm sorry!
Oh, okay.
Did he accept my apology?
Oh, I did it.
Oh, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry!
I don't have my tickets!
I used it all!
No!
I used all my tickets!
Oh, you can't get through that.
I know you can't.
Oh!
I do- Okay!
I assume he was too thick for the door!
I guess he can- Okay!
Like, I assume that he was too big for the door!
Fuck me for not- For forgetting that he could just smash through it!
Okay!
And he turned that- I'm gonna stop playing with it!
They knew- Okay!
But like- Rationally!
He was too thick for that door!
So I assumed that I could just stand there!
He wasn't too big for the ceiling!
Oh my- Oh my god!
Of course- Of course!
They blocked the door!
There you go!
It gets these!
Tickets, please!
I'm crawling as fast as I can!
Oh!
Jesus Christ!
Surely I can safely go through here, right?
But, like, I can go through here now, right?
Kids, please.
Okay, that seems safe.
I don't know anymore.
Oh, I don't want to touch these guys.
They're, like, they're just gonna scream and be like, man, I wish I could paint.
Woo!
What the?
It was not safe.
It was not safe, guys.
Not safe.
Where do I go?
Oh!
Hello!
Yay!
Guys, he doesn't like freeloaders, guys.
Alright.
It's like those trained people that are like, Ticket, please.
What the fuck do you mean, don't get lazy?
I got fucking chased by a ticket, man!
I found the location of another upgrade station.
It's a no ticket.
No, it's like no bitches.
Bro just wanted some tickets.
Yeah, and he, and my fucking dispatcher didn't give me no tickets.
Where the fuck were my tickets, dispatcher?
Hey, buddy.
Check in when you have a chance.
Alright.
I'm gonna check in.
No tickets?
Hello.
I am dying to know what happened in there.
The system was flooded with alarms and alerts, and then it all stopped.
I'm guessing you took care of it.
Well done.
No, no, no.
I almost died again.
You need to send help.
I can't talk?
Get me out of here now.
Oh my god, wait.
A rational main character?
First, the system says the data diver was updated to include creator permissions.
I have free will?
I guess that means you're an artist now.
Good job.
I knew you could do it.
As for your real job, your next target is the upgrade station in the demonstration theater.
Check the map.
You can get there through the workshops.
Yeah, check the map.
Uh...
Oh, okay.
It's already there.
Wait, where's there?
Oh, okay.
It's the door with the elephant.
I got you.
Oh, he had only 30...
He was up for 36 hours already.
Alright.
Tickets, please.
This should be lit.
Yeah?
No, that's the theater.
Oh, wait.
No, yeah.
He wanted me to go to the theater.
How much money I get?
25 whole dollars for two slices...
For two slices of pizza at Freddy Fazbear Pizzeria.
Get right now for 9.99.
Oh, there's lockers.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no.
Oh, there's lockers.
Oh, no.
I lost my hand.
Oh.
I fucked it.
No!
I fucked it up!
My hand's still in there!
You can't go!
Nevermind.
I lost the hand.
Come on!
You can't close it!
My hand's right in there!
He can and he will close it.
There we go.
I feel like something's gonna be in front of me.
It is such a bitch to rotate.
It actually is.
I hear someone.
Just walking over.
Just waddling, honestly.
Who's that?
I feel like this game was originally made for VR.
And then VR died.
And then they ported it to like a beat.
And then they ported it here.
This feels like it was originally made for VR.
Yeah, because a lot of the puzzles require me to move my hands.
Who's that?
Oh, it's B!
Oh my god.
He is...
Worse.
He looks a lot worse.
Ever since the show got cancelled, he wasn't the same.
What the fuck?
He's just...
camping me.
I don't know where to go.
Like, I don't know what power I fixed in general.
Like, what the fuck did I fix?
A fence?
No object permanence.
Where did I go?
I don't even know myself.
That's right.
I don't know what to do though.
Bro, he's fucking huge.
How...
How much does he weigh?
He's literally vibrating the floor right now.
There's no lockers here.
There's no...
No!
I thought there was a locker!
Ah!
I thought there was a locker there!
Okay.
Alright.
I couldn't see it!
I was blind!
Wait.
What the fuck is that?
That's a banana!
What is that?
He heard a Playstation is making another...
Oh yeah.
I heard they're making a Playstation 6.
Maybe they'll put games on it this time.
I want the grand prize.
No you don't.
Yay!
Oh, he doesn't hear that!
But here's my tiny ass fucking stick legs!
He hears my stick legs!
I can't even fucking jump!
Wait.
I don't know if I should go down here.
I heard you didn't like Honey and Nuts and your Honey and that Cheerios.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Gladstone.
Notice to all workers.
All late night shenanigans are to stop immediately.
I have some very important TV people coming to look at the show template.
I can't have the projector breaking again.
Oh.
Anything here?
I don't think so.
Let me uh...
Chat died.
So I gotta fix that real quick, guys.
Sorry.
Immersion lost!
Alright, there we go.
Oh hey, there's a movie here.
Free movie!
Movie night!
Movie night?
Oh, wait.
Wait, who took the movie?
No!
Somebody ruined free movie night!
Who the fuck ruined free movie night?
Alright.
Do I have any new logs?
No.
Okay.
And...
I don't think there's anything here.
Wait, can I open this?
Oh, I can.
What's in here?
Oh, there you go!
There's my free movie!
That's the shittiest fucking safe I've ever seen.
Didn't even have a path.
It was just like, do this puzzle.
Do this three-year-old puzzle to see if you have had eye coordination.
Oh, it's Fiona!
You look terrible!
Ah!
So much to do by morning.
I'll never be ready for my big presentation.
All I wanna do is sleep.
This is...
Sorry, they had like, ten dollars for the animation budget.
Stay up late.
No.
Latte.
No shadow.
Immersion ruin.
Is this annoying orange?
Rich and roasted, yet creamy and sweet.
Give me more!
That's Murray's secret recipe.
This day a latte creates the perfect cup of coffee suited to you.
This is your coffee habit.
I know what you want better than you do.
I am always watching, watching and learning.
Oh, that's not scary.
That's just AI!
Look!
I'm in the movie!
Did you stay up all night?
Oh, it just plays it again and again.
That's me!
Oh, that's Fiona!
I'm in the movie, guys!
The outside is dangerous.
I don't wanna go outside.
Wait!
Oh!
Did I miss a number?
Was there a number in here?
I didn't see a number.
I'm exhausted.
So much to do by morning.
I'll never be ready for my big presentation.
All I wanna do is sleep.
I think so.
I didn't see a number.
Why sleep when you can stay up latte?
Wait, there was a number in there?
Stay up late?
No.
Latte.
Wait, I gotta see this number.
Sorry, guys.
I'm re-watching it.
I wanna know what I missed.
Mmm.
Distinctive taste.
Rich and roasted, yet creamy.
What was the number?
Oh, you guys got the number for me?
I was too busy looking at my- My first movie appearance.
Right here.
This is my first- The first time I ever appeared.
In a film.
I know what you want better than you do.
I am always watching.
Watching and learning.
Have another cup.
Another cup.
Did you stay up all night?
No.
I stayed up latte.
Attay.
After two full bars, I'm ready to work.
Promotion?
Here I come!
That's the merdipment.
Yeah!
What the fuck was the number?
Alright, I trust you guys got the number.
Oh hey, there's another collectible.
You got mail!
Got another collectible!
Oh, it doesn't come until later?
I fucking knew you guys were gaslighting.
That chat, is this real?
Alright, left or right?
Guys, left or right?
Right side, there's a bee that told me to go outside and touch grass, so I don't know.
Right is more scary.
Okay, I'm going left.
Wait, do I have it?
Oh fuck.
I guess I go right.
Never mind.
We go to the room that's more scary.
I
just...
I guess...
What?
Hello?
Mail time?
Alright, we go this way.
Everything looks so fine, guys.
It's so fine and healthy.
Let's see.
Alright, we go through here.
Yeah, it does look like I gotta run soon.
I think this is like the loading section.
Because they're loading the next place.
Oh guys, remember that code?
From like 80 years ago?
This is your moment, guys!
It's the code!
Right here!
That one code!
It's not boob, I know.
At chat!
That's the first code we saw!
What do you mean?
It's the...
Okay, four...
Four...
Two...
Three...
Okay, it's five numbers.
Two...
Six...
Nine...
Four...
There we go.
The first code we ever saw.
We finally gotta use it.
Wait, there's another...
I knew you guys could remember it.
I've always believed in you.
That's why I never remember it myself.
Okay, so this is the employee's room.
Everybody really fucking loves Freddy Fazbear Pizzeria.
Aw, man.
Is there like...
An area closer?
For me to store this?
Aw...
Yeah, but I wanna get the collectible too.
Did I come back to it?
Where the fuck is the...
Gonna chuck that here.
And then...
Grab this.
And then I got a lunchbox now.
Wait...
From where I have the door.
There's no way she'll come for me in the bathroom.
Oh...
I don't like this.
Feels like she wants to...
Come into the bathroom.
Alright, what does this...
What do the crack do?
Where did I put my film?
Oh my god, it chucked too many.
I can't see.
Oh my god, where did I put it?
Oh my god, I lost the film!
We hit it!
Oh no, I juggled it too much, guys.
I juggled the film too much!
Oh!
It actually disappeared!
It...
It's gone!
What?
But we got the connectable!
What happened to it?
Where did it go?
Can it be back in the save?
Can it do that?
I don't like that.
No.
Oh.
It actually...
It disappeared!
It's...
Okay, let's turn up the brightness.
I need to know what happened to it.
Alright, don't worry.
I'll...
I'll lower it back.
I...
I cannot see.
I tried to do something cool and juggle it, but it didn't work.
Oops.
Okay, I'm just trying...
Oh my god!
Wait, what if I play the game like this?
Wait, it's actually gone!
Wait!
It's...
And this game is less scary though.
Oh my god!
No, I don't think it's in the bathroom.
I think it actually...
It's gone, gone.
It's...
It's gone!
Okay.
Guys, we have to die!
We actually have to die!
It...
Wait, it's next to the trash bag?
Where is it?
Did you guys see it?
Did you see it?
Wait...
I'm next to the trash bag.
Where is it?
I can't believe it!
I...
I got what...
Oh my god!
Even dad's angry!
He's like...
How could you lose it?
How did you lose it?
Oh my god!
And the thing was right there!
It was right there!
Can we...
We...
We actually...
We have to reload...
We...
Wait...
Okay, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Maybe he'll kill me before...
What?
Before I come back.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Where is she?
Can she just kill me?
Oh my...
Just kill me!
Just...
Put me out of my misery!
Okay, guys.
We have to reload this.
We...
We actually have to reload it.
I...
Cause I...
Cause like...
I don't know where the fuck the film went.
It actually like...
Disappeared.
Oh!
Oh my god!
I thought I had to go back from the beginning.
I thought they put me back in the car.
I...
What happened?
I lost the film!
Oh my god!
This game is a lot less scary now.
Okay.
Uh...
Graphics.
Brightness.
Nah, I wanna play it.
What if I just play it at...
At that brightness?
Wow!
Wait, where did I go?
I don't even remember.
Which way did I went?
Did I get the mail yet?
It's here, right?
Oh my god!
I don't remember where...
Where I went.
Ah!
Fucking everything...
Is blurring together.
Okay, I went through here.
And then...
The cell phone.
Yeah.
Alright.
Unlock.
Okay, what was the...
What was the silly number again, guys?
Guys.
Come on.
I know you guys know this number.
Guys, it's not boobs.
Boobs.
One day it will be boobs.
But today is not that day.
Two, six, two, nine, four.
Two...
Six...
Nine...
Four.
One day it will be that day.
But it's not today.
Doki boobs is not silly.
Alright.
This time.
We got it.
It's time we got it.
For God, it's not just a quick swipe.
Wait, can I put the film in the storage?
Am I allowed to?
Oh, yes, I can.
Oh, thank God.
That's good.
Okay, I didn't break it this time, chat.
The film did not fucking evaporate it under the floor.
I think I broke this game like eight times.
Alright, nice.
Oh, that's the elevator.
Wait, where do I go?
At chat, I'm lost.
I don't recognize this place.
Returns?
Do I have that?
No.
I'm lost.
I don't know.
Thank you, guys.
Oh, it's the...
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, wait, it's here.
I'm back here.
Wait, why is the light glowing on this particular area?
Do I have this?
No.
Where do I...
No, there's nothing on the forklift.
I mean, can I access the forklift?
Can I push the forklift?
There's a door here.
Here, workshop?
Here?
I'm back here.
Oh my god, I'm not forklift certified.
I need to get certified first.
I'm back in the workshop.
Theater?
No, I came from a theater.
Yeah, I came from a theater.
Wait, no.
There's two theaters?
Wait, where did I come from?
Where...
I'm so lost.
Oh, maybe here.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, this is where...
Oh, I know this!
This is where they make the animatronics.
See, that's where they construct it.
Hey, Arnold.
The system says you need a suit to get into the theater.
Alright, put it in me.
I saw dead by daylight.
He seemed so fine.
He seemed mentally okay.
Uh...
Start assembly.
Alright.
That's it.
Pieces of updated...
Can we found...
Oh, I have to find the pieces of it.
Okay.
I like listening to her talk to me as if I'm a regular person.
Welcome to our more famous costume workshop.
If you are not an MCM employee, please proceed to...
Joke's on you!
I am!
Backstage theater access is restricted to potential plants and demonstration...
I got promotion!
Spring lock assembly may be required.
Oh.
Please ensure there are no hazards that could cause issues.
Oh, that's freaky.
Mr. Helpful is worried about the effects of moisture on the suit's functionality and safety.
Wait, what's this access, though?
What is this getting me?
Yeah, she said the word, guys!
She said spring lock!
Ah!
Okay.
Boy, spring lock's bad.
Doesn't that crush me?
Use the costume lift to access the theater booth.
It won't operate unless you're wearing the suit.
Okay.
Once you're in place, the stage manager program will guide you through the demonstration.
Good luck!
Oh, I mean, break a leg.
Sorry!
Oh, there's another recording.
David, I want to introduce you to someone.
This is M1.
M1?
Why does it look like that?
It's scary.
Okay, everything your dad made is scary.
It'll wear fun costumes.
M1?
David, everything your dad makes is a fucking freak show.
Think of it as your new babysitter.
But if it doesn't get paid and go home, it'll stay with us.
And help around the house.
Okay.
Oh, so that was the Mic Mic.
It's like an unpaid babysitter.
But that's still more expensive than a regular babysitter.
Because that shit must have cost thousands of dollars.
When you can just pay...
And a teenager...
Like, below minimum wage.
Alright.
Ralph went to the hospital last night.
That suit is going to be the death of one of us.
One more injury and I'm...
And I'm out of here.
I mean it this time.
I know, I know.
I don't think it's that big of a problem.
The misspelling actually helps us when it comes to possible copyright issues.
The double L spelling protects us.
Nobody will notice anyway.
Ed, how many times did I tell you this?
Uh...
Mycelium only has one L.
Now all the marking images are misspelled.
Our clients are going to think we make mistakes and don't pay attention to the details.
Is there any way on how to fix it?
Guys, it's copyright law.
It's like how someone can name themselves Doko Bird and then like I can't do shit about it.
Oh my god, is that Doko Bird?
Doko Bird?
Okay.
I need to find the head.
Can I just wear these guys?
Doko Bird.
I have Doko Bird.
Oh god.
Oh hey there.
Let me pet you.
I wanna touch your head.
Come on, let me touch your head.
Come on little guy.
Oh my god.
Let me touch your head.
There he is.
Good boy.
Who's a good boy?
There you go.
He let me touch his head.
Where do I find the rest of this fucking suit?
Hey Arnold.
The system says you need a suit to get into the theater.
Oh, I have to go out now?
Oh no.
What?
There's nothing up here.
Where are you?
Oh my god, that's a leg.
Where do I go through so loud?
I don't know where I am.
Oh my god, there's the other leg.
I found the other leg though.
Guys, do you think it's gonna clip through again?
I have two legs.
Alright.
Okay, I got a leg.
I got one of the legs.
Where's my other leg?
Okay, there's the other leg.
Oh!
He just gets a TP like that?
Oh my god, I hope my leg is still on that floor.
I hope my leg is still on this plane of existence.
I hope it's still on this plane of existence in this 3D floor right in front of me.
Okay.
Oh my god, it is.
Oh, thank god.
I'm glad it didn't noclip.
That's all I wanted.
I only want one thing.
To make sure this shit does a noclip.
Okay, now I need to figure out where the fuck the head is.
No head?
The fuck is that head?
Oh wait, mail time though.
Mail is always important.
Mail time.
We just got a letter.
Wonder who it would be.
Is that the head?
Oh my god.
There you go.
It's fine.
We have to lower the head down.
Okay.
We're fine.
It's so fast.
Please.
Go downstairs.
Is that mushroom?
I don't know what's in it.
What if I just like...
There's like no eye.
Oh my god.
It's so freaky.
A freaky little guy.
Okay.
Not gonna lie.
If they can make animatronics like this.
Like...
They should sell that to the government.
Like you can fucking build a terminator at that point.
And we're using it to build killed kids animatronics.
Like send that guy out to war.
Oh my god.
United States using an army of FNAF animatronics.
Like that's literally Terminator right there.
Why the fuck are we using...
Why is the US government not using this technology?
Deploying Freddy Fazbear.
Sir.
Sir, we gotta deploy him.
But he's not ready yet.
Whoops.
He heard that?
Something something human rights.
We're sending...
We're letting these guys kill our children.
Fuck you send William Afton into the front lines.
Apparently he can't die.
Letting is a strong word.
Alright.
Let's find...
LEAVE!
OH MY GOD!
Alright.
Bro, this...
This fucking factory could make millions of dollars.
Instead, he's just killing kids.
Yeah.
I think there's like a locker right down here.
Oh my god, he was like right behind me.
C'mon!
Cyclone!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Fuck them kids!
John Cena!
Where is he running to?
Is he lost?
I don't even know where I lowered this shit.
He just had too much energy apparently.
Oh!
What the fuck the- Where the fuck do you- Why did he teleported behind me?
He was- He actually teleported!
Oh my god, that head better be there.
That head better be on that exact same 3D plane of existence.
I swear to god, if he goes 4D, I swear to god.
Bro, he took swap clothes!
Where did I throw the head?
Oh my god, I don't know where I threw it.
Where did I throw it?
It's right here.
Oh, it's right here.
Oh my god, why- Why is this so heavy?
Oh wait, he did it.
Oh my god, we did it.
Oh, I forgot he needs arms.
Does he?
No, he doesn't need arms.
Hey, Arnold's here.
No, he needs arms!
Well, just use my arms!
He can't tell the difference!
There's no way he can tell the difference!
Oh my god, where are the arms?
I only found legs.
I never got that far.
I only saw legs!
Oh no, I...
Oh!
I was cheating!
It was right next to me!
Oh, thank god.
At least it saved me with the head.
I don't have to do the whole thing again.
That's actually crazy.
Yeah, but it didn't work!
He literally teleported behind me!
Or, like, behind me, teleported in front of me and was like, fuck you in particular.
Like, you don't!
That's bullshit!
That's actually bullshit!
What the fuck are the hands?
There's only legs here!
Oh, I see our legs!
What, you saw them?
I hear them.
Thingy nose.
Does he think he knew?
Yes, I think he did.
No.
Alright.
I don't know.
Like, we locked eyes, but I had, you know, I thought he was a homie.
You may- I don't know.
We did make eye contact, but I thought, you know, he was gonna turn around.
I thought he'd be a homie, you know?
Oh, no.
Not now.
I didn't mean turn around now.
It's not what I mean!
But I said turn around!
He did see it.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Might as well just die.
Might as well.
Might as well restart!
The fuck is he going?
Okay.
The arm is downstairs.
What the fuck is- Is it this arm?
Oh, it's right here!
I swear!
I swear to God, if this guy fucking comes to life, I swear to God.
Oh my god.
I went the wrong way.
I got lost.
I got- I got lost!
Alright.
Arm number one!
Okay, arm number two time.
Don't hear him.
You come to life, I swear to God.
Oh, it's this area.
No man?
Wait, where's the other arm then?
Wait, where would the other arm be?
Wait,
where would the other arm be?
Is the other arm in that same area?
Do I have to go straight to that area?
Where the fuck is the last arm?
Where
the fuck is the last arm?
Oh my god.
He's so jolly.
It's on the bottom floor.
Okay.
I'll go this way then.
Where the fuck is the last arm?
Hello?
It's somewhere he- Guys, thank you.
Wow.
It's somewhere here.
It's just here.
Somewhere.
Wait, I passed it?
It wasn't even glowing.
I can't walk over.
Somewhere there!
How did I fucking pass it?
We locked eyes, but then he just went on the other side.
Guys, I think- I don't think he- I think he saw me.
Oh, it was hanging on the wall of chains.
Oh, it's knock- Oh my god, that's actually bullshit.
They actually made it not glowing this time.
All the other parts are glowing!
It's not glowing!
And then you're like, fuck it.
You know everything you learned from playing this game?
Now you gotta- Now it's not glowing!
Yeah?
You saw me?
Is there somewhere here?
Am I hot or cold?
What's this?
I passed it again?!
Is this where I got my arm?
Oh my god.
I don't know if you guys are fucking with me.
That's the worst part.
I don't know if you guys are fucking- It's in the- Wait, that bucket right here?
Okay, now I feel like you're fucking with me.
I- You're hot, but I don't know where the arm is.
I- Ha-haha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Okay.
Okay, now I definitely know you're fucking- What the
fuck is this stupid arm...
Oh hey, I got a mouse.
Okay.
I got it outta here.
What the fuck is this stupid goddamn man?
Get out of here.
I don't know.
It's in that room?
The room where I just fucking threw a mouse in?
He's confused.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's in that room.
Okay.
I gotta... I gotta wait until he leaves.
Is he right beside me?
We locked eyes, but I don't think he saw me.
Okay.
I'm gonna throw another mouse in here.
Where did I pick up the rat?
Wait, I don't remember where I picked up the rat.
Oh, there he is.
I can look into that room.
Oh, he's gonna go that way!
Okay.
He's gonna... He's gonna go that way!
Okay!
Of course, it went all the way around.
I played myself.
Okay.
It's in this room.
Where is it?
Where's the goddamn fucking arm?!
Oh my god, I'm gonna go crazy.
Oh, fuck!
It's right here.
No!
Oh my god!
Oh, that was close!
That was close!
Oh my god, that was close!
Oh, that was so close!
I don't know where he is.
Please let me get to the end.
This is...
Gonna be very risky.
Oh my god, I fucking finally got the arm!
Oh my god, thank you!
Finally!
Become one with me!
Become one!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I have to restart this.
Okay.
Can't become one yet.
Energize spring lock.
Actually, nothing's gonna go wrong if I activate the spring lock.
All right.
Let's go.
Oh man.
Yep.
Nothing's gonna go wrong now.
Oh hey, nice.
I can...
Go to a boss.
Where am I supposed to go again?
Okay, you're big.
See, that's what I mean!
How the fuck were they able to get through the door?
All right, here I go.
Take me down!
Let me perform for the children!
All right, I think I'm one of them.
Oh.
Oh, I don't think they...
I don't think they think that anymore.
Hey guys!
I'm one of you.
Oh, hey!
Friends!
We're friends!
Look at that!
You said hi!
That fucking idiot.
Can I do this?
No.
I knew it.
Oh my god!
What am I doing?
I didn't know I could get outside!
Imagine if I did that right next to him.
I didn't even know you could leave!
I didn't know!
I didn't think I could just leave my suit!
My safety suit!
All right.
I thought I was gonna be there forever!
Yeah, open the lever.
Oh my god!
It's another puzzle time!
Okay.
Then...
Wait, where...
Oh!
I can't even fix this!
Oh, what the fuck?
It's broken anyway!
Oh!
Never mind!
Guys, I fixed it!
Okay!
It was just that easy!
There we go!
I didn't know it was just the side of the machine!
Land!
No time limit!
Look at that!
Guys, it was a speed run tech!
So, I didn't have to feel pressured with the time limit!
It's so smart!
Where's your speed here?
Oh!
Okay, but without me...
No, I feel like...
I'm not going back...
Oh!
I can't go back to the suit!
No!
I can't!
Because...
My skinny ass legs can't fucking jump!
Okay.
Oh god!
I need to...
I need to get back in the suit, Doki!
What if I don't want to get back in the suit?
Okay, like...
How?
This is super risky.
What I'm doing is very...
Okay, I didn't think she would turn around.
Okay.
I don't know where the other...
Where the other locker was.
I don't remember.
Get back in the suit, Doki!
No, I don't think he has thumbs.
You can't open a locker.
Got your thumbs.
I actually don't know.
I don't remember where the other locker is.
What's right there?
Yeah, that's right.
That's fucking right.
What you gonna do?
Open my locker?
That's right.
I know you have no thumbs.
Stupid.
I'm your friend.
Friend!
Hi.
I'm friend.
That's right.
I was always here.
Oh my god.
Where did that stupid guy went?
I know, right?
Where did he go?
Don't worry, friend.
We'll get him next time.
Oh my god.
Word.
Did you see that human just now?
Man.
Must have missed him.
I didn't see him at all.
It's a mystery.
Okay.
All right.
Should be safe here now.
I'll get out of here.
Whoops.
I blocked myself.
Don't worry.
I just...
There we go.
I turned my...
Just turned myself around.
There we go.
Thanks.
You weren't even supposed to be there.
You were supposed to be here.
Me and David.
Oh, how am I supposed to tell David that his mother is gone?
Wait, what?
How did the mom die?
He does not sound sad that his fucking wife died.
Wait, what?
Why does he just sound annoyed?
Like, your fucking wife died.
He just sounds like...
Aw, man.
What am I gonna do now?
Who's gonna take care of the child?
Aw, shucks.
My mom...
My wife died.
Yeah, it sounds like a minor inconvenience.
Me and Stan are out of here.
It's time to jump ship before things get ugly.
I have a bunch of Fiona's character patterns.
And Stan is taking what he can.
Uh...
Oh, I have a bunch of Fiona's character patterns.
And Stan is taking what he can.
Join us.
With everything we know about the restaurant project, we can start our own machine shop.
Vacation.
My weekend vacation request was refused.
I quit.
Tell Jake I'll be back for my things on Monday.
Uh, Lee, the projector is down again in the theater.
I swear.
This super show is cursed.
What was Edwin thinking?
Making this kid's thing.
Plus, those things just creep me out.
Okay, something was trying to talk to me earlier.
I think it's the mimic.
Hello?
I'm here for the show.
I'm not here for the show.
Oh, I have to get out here.
Okay, never mind.
Okay, now I'm here for the show.
Wait, what?
Wait, is that target?
There's a target down here.
Oh, okay.
Okay, for real this time.
Now I'm actually here for the show.
Welcome, potential investors and buyers.
That's me.
Are you getting into the children's television entertainment space?
Yeah?
Are the costs of writers, crew, and puppeteers holding you back?
Yeah, I know, right?
Paying wages?
No news for you.
Welcome to the MCM television studio of the future.
Here, there's no need for a cast of crew.
Our patented stage manager software keeps your show on track and condensed to fit your broadcast time slot, including commercial breaks.
If writers have you blocked, use the MCM story templates.
Why are you choosing me?
I'm listening to lore!
It's lore!
Page manager with the desired character names, location, and genre.
It writes itself.
Additional story templates available for purchase.
What about the talent?
Well, we removed the talent.
What?
No difficult puppeteers.
Oh my god, it's like AI.
Our system is drama-free.
Oh my god, we're using AI.
By shooting targets to progress the story.
And of course, you'll save a fortune on production costs.
The MCM studio comes equipped with automated cameras, props, and lights.
He's an AI bro!
This example show is written and performed by a single costumed writer, director, cameraman, puppeteer, producer, in front of an automated studio audience.
All right, there was a little tiger there that wanted to fucking kill me.
Get in line!
They all want to kill me!
That's the secret!
Wait, where did the tiger go?
Oh, I don't have access to this.
He's forgetting.
I don't like that the mimic is using children, children's voices right now.
What's this?
What am I supposed to do?
I'm in a creating machine right now?
Oh!
I'm gonna move this closer!
Where am I supposed to go, though?
Am I supposed to go to the other side?
Wait.
Okay.
I have this?
No, okay.
I have to go to the other side.
Okay, I get it.
I wasn't sure where the pathway was.
I understand for real now.
I understand this time.
Okay.
That has to be the end of that area.
And then...
Remove that.
Wouldn't it be easier if we just had two bridges?
Is this really saving money?
Why don't he just build two bridges?
Like, every time I need to cross the bridge, I gotta play a crane game.
Oh yeah, and using the power to operate this is much more cheaper.
Is he stupid?
Isn't that it?
Yeah, is he fucking stupid?
Just build a bridge!
Oh wait, I was supposed to go down.
I was supposed to go here.
And lower this.
What am I lowering?
Oh, another bridge.
Oh, I have to lower both bridges.
Crank that soldier boy.
There we go.
And I just need to hit that target so I have to go back.
We don't make sense here.
We make dollars.
They give this super chat.
I'm so thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, I gotta go down now.
I'll go back to my suit.
Oh my god.
All right, Apako.
This company's gonna go.
It's already in debt.
That's why.
That's why nobody's alive.
That's why you don't see anybody.
All right.
Time to go downstairs.
Okay.
Oh my god, am I the main star?
Oh, there's Foxy.
Oh my god, it's pilot Foxy.
Down in the dark smoke.
Today's the big surprise party.
You should be excited.
I'm sad because today is the big surprise party.
Okay, this feels AI generated.
I forgot it's a gift.
It's a disaster.
Make me up a kid's play with Foxy.
Shiver.
Timbers.
No gift.
All hands on deck.
Foxy was an idea.
Oh my god, William Henry did steal Foxy!
Oh wait, that's the... that's not a collectible.
Wait, was Roxy their IP too?
Oh my god, there's Roxy!
They stole Foxy and Roxy!
We shall copyright that!
Dude, that is actually so creepy.
We're supposed to shoot that, right?
Okay.
I'm shooting targets, am I doing it?
I don't know if I'm actually supposed to shoot the targets.
I don't know, am I winning?
I can't tell!
There's so many targets!
Am I winning?
Oh, I did it!
I won!
I got a gift!
What?
Bonjour, Monsieur Foxy!
The snacks are ready!
Bernard, how much did he make?
Hello, there was no gift!
So, I made a little extra...
Wait, the set is collapsing!
What?
No party snacks?
What now, Foxy?
Oh, I have to...
Okay, I realized...
I was not supposed to shoot the birds!
But where are the party snacks?
Oh, there's...
Oh, there's some here!
Oh, I'm like actually changing everything!
They're like...
They're like booing because I shot the audience!
No party snacks!
Foxy said no!
I'm gonna shoot my crewmate...
Eh...
Jesus Christ...
I don't know like...
I don't know if I'm accomplishing anything!
I...
Oh, awesome!
Oh, that's for me!
Oh!
Well done!
Awesome!
Foxy!
Rocktopus!
Rocktopus on the starboard bow!
Rocktopus?
Where's the Rocktopus?
Foxy!
Oh, I like how the set was broken right here.
Rocktopi are drawn to boat parties!
This is why sailors don't have boat parties!
Hey, Meowth!
That's Rocktopus!
What do you got to eat?
Come on, lad!
Stop that, bro!
Well, Mary Jane...
That's my favorite name, Scoob!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Yeah, I killed the octopus.
Okay, now I'm doing stuff.
Now I'm actually doing stuff.
Don't worry, I'm contributing to the team!
I'm just destroying, like, thousands of dollars worth of property.
Let's go.
We're in my $25 gift card.
Oh my god, it's so far away.
Oh no, he's going!
No, I'm sorry!
I'm doing my best!
I'm shooting everything!
Okay.
Yay!
Jesus, how many fucking...
Oh, there's eight.
I know, right?
It's not radical.
Okay.
We all work together for once.
Like a real crew.
You've made me the happiest captain on the second scene.
Foxy!
You did it!
You found the...
This is very scary.
If, like, I was in this building and everything is collapsing around me...
Then, like, the whole fucking building's gonna collapse.
Foxy!
My birthday was last week!
Aww...
Forgot his birthday!
Oh, it's falling apart because...
Um, everything...
Every time I shoot a target, it changes the set.
And I think because the set is really fucking old.
Um...
And it hasn't been used in, like, years.
It's, like, more...
Like, it's, like, not well-maintained.
It's also AI-generated.
What?
Who are you?
Your star?
Yeah, the set was AI-generated.
Huh?
Wait, is this Fiona's voice?
Oh, wait, no, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
He's my friend!
To soften up the remaining organic materials...
No, no, sorry!
It-it-it-it's just a friend inside!
Finally, we will flush out your interior with a power hose.
Then give you a nice, long soak in the bleach bath.
You will be ship-shape in no time.
Please wait here until your number is called.
There are 4,625 paths ahead of you.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, nice.
We're in the queue.
That's good.
Okay, that's good.
We're in the queue.
So it'll be like at least 20 more years until she calls on me.
Thank god.
We're safe.
I'm very excited about our next showroom.
Welcome to the world's first recycling center.
Recycling center?
Basically, we take trash and turn it into cash.
To explain how it all works.
Contact your friendly cells represent- Oh, there's Nurse Dolly!
Recycling automation.
Say hello, Nurse Dolly.
Hello, Nurse Dolly.
That's here.
I thought it would be fun to go with a doll hospital fee.
Pretty neat, huh?
Dolly, tell them what you do.
I am recycling.
Edwin Murray coined the term and it will soon be an industry standard.
Edwin invented recycling.
Okay.
I think he might have a little god complex.
Before Edwin, all we did was just throw our garbage away.
Into our pit.
Thank god, Edwin invented recycling.
We do like various discarded materials.
I'm talking about broken midway games, costumes, computer...
Oh, we do about Edwin.
Toasters, and precious metals.
Those useless things are then used to create new midway games, costumes, and technologies for your family fun centers.
What is she doing?
And what we can't use is broken down into its basic components.
Which we then sell it a profit.
Oh, she's gonna kill me.
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh.
Oh, I realized this door opens up to that, to that room.
I just realized.
Oh, hello!
Okay.
Okay, she can't kill me here.
I have a little space.
Okay, open the vent.
I have a little space that I can just chill in.
Okay, I just need her to go across, and then I'll just wait from behind.
Yeah, she's on a set path.
So I can just wait for her back here.
Alright, nice.
Alright, wait.
Is there anything over there?
Oh, I...
She just turned around.
She can do that?
Wait, is there anything back there?
Is there collectible back there?
Nah.
I just want to be sure.
Okay.
I'll go in.
Yeah, I was going to say, she turned around.
That's like cheating.
I'm not going to...
Okay.
I knew it.
I knew there was nothing back there.
I fucking knew it.
I knew you guys lied.
Wait, she turned around again.
It's cheating.
Yeah.
Okay.
Ah!
Fucking hell.
Jesus.
Oh my god, it's mail time.
I didn't realize it's mail time.
Goddamn mail time.
Where do I do with this?
Where do I put this?
Hello.
Oh, it's right here.
Okay, I got worried that...
Oh, I can open the door now.
Okay, I feel like she's gonna run over me.
I need her to go around from here.
I need her to go around.
I feel like she'll run over me.
Yeah, and the PC had like open big door.
Where is she going?
The pathway is so random now.
Okay.
Now I can open the door.
Here we go.
Nice.
Doesn't she recognize me?
The foreign object?
She can literally scan me right now.
Wait, is she broken?
What's going on?
Wait a minute.
She can do that?
I don't want to take my medicine.
The mimic got her?
What the fuck?
Oh, I got meds.
Okay.
Okay, I think the mimic got her.
I don't want to take my meds.
I don't think she saw me.
Ladies, if I take my meds, the voices will disappear.
My chat will disappear.
Recycle.
No, she destroyed.
I don't think she saw me.
Oh, thank God she's stupid.
How would I get back seated if I take my meds?
Medical personnel only.
Okay, I need her to like, get through the...
Like, where did her feet go?
Wait, is she wearing heels now?
Oh my God, it's just gone.
But she literally just like, got up.
I can't...
I can't power it up.
She's literally capping me.
Please leave.
Please.
I just want to crank that soldier boy.
Please let me crank that soldier boy!
It's right there!
That arm using the bathroom.
She's just gonna capped me for a bell.
I'm using the bathroom.
No disassemble.
Error.
I will try turning it off and on again.
We need to run some tests.
Fix, fix, fix.
You need a lobotomy.
Next task.
Time to take your medicine.
Back for real.
Is she still there?
She's still there.
Like, I...
Please.
I just want to crank it.
Let me crank that soldier boy.
Scanning.
Okay.
Please, I don't need a...
You can't fix me.
Okay.
Here we go.
We did it.
True!
Wait, do I go down?
I don't know.
No, down is not up.
Okay.
Here we go.
We got out of there.
Kiwi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, now we're safe.
Alright, what's this?
Uh...
Access Doll Hospital.
I don't know what that is.
Oh.
That's fire.
What about cards?
Oh, it's time cards.
Oh, Barbara Chris Milton.
Isn't Milton a character?
Red flag, what did he do?
Come on, I'm pretty sure Milton's a nice guy.
Isn't he, like, from the FNAF universe?
Into the pit we go.
Oh, there's more mail.
Mail time.
Yay, I got mail!
You got mail.
Okay, where...
Where am I?
Oh, no signal.
Never mind.
I guess I'll never know.
Alright, I swear.
If I hear that song one more time, I'm going to tear that dolly off her hinges.
I have no clue how much longer I can take it here.
All personnel are expected to meet their energy quotas before returning home.
No exceptions.
Alright, Milton.
How are you gonna know?
Limbs replaced...
Oh, look!
They can replace limbs!
What a great place to work at.
See?
Look at that.
Even if you...
You lose your hand.
At least you'll get a sick cool robot hand.
For free?
Yeah, who needs regular hands when I get...
Robo hands.
She sounds dangerous.
Is she getting closer?
There's so many levers.
I'm just turning on all the levers.
I don't know what they do.
I am unable to access your service manual.
Now no one will make fun of my spaghetti arms.
What is that?
I have no idea where she's going.
I have no map sense.
What's this?
Oh, it's for the chute.
But where's the chute?
Oh, that's...
No, that's not the chute.
Wait, where's the chute?
Oh, that's...
It's right next to me.
There we go.
Okay, so now I have to find other trash.
Oh, but mail.
Mail's important.
Gotta check my mail.
We're gonna find more trash.
Okay.
She just opened the door?
What?
Wait.
Was that supposed to happen?
She has thumbs?
No.
Oh, no.
AI is getting stronger.
What the?
Since when?
No!
She has a possible thumbs!
She is learning?!
The horror!
Oh, my God.
I can just stand behind her, right?
Actually, I can go...
Oh, she's going right...
Left side.
I just need to go right.
I need to grab that.
Oh.
She didn't see me.
Okay, but where is the other...
Garbage?
There has to be more garbage!
To the right side.
I think.
I didn't see any garbage.
My God, this is a lot bigger than I expected.
This is...
This is a lot bigger.
Oh, this is a lot bigger.
Oh, there's a lot more stuff here than I thought.
There is a...
Oh!
There is a lot more stuff here.
I have an idea.
It's time.
Surely, this time, they won't...
Surely...
Surely, it won't phase through this time.
Oh, man, though.
Unlock this.
Oh, wait.
I don't...
I do this first.
Alright.
It's been so long since I did this one puzzle.
Wait, what?
Wait, no puzzle?
No puzzle!
Nevermind.
Um...
Okay.
What?
Wait.
Excuse me?
What happens when I touch the corrupted thing?
Oh, I have to make it...
I forgot.
I have to make it all fucking ones.
Why do I keep making them zero?
I don't know!
I don't...
I can't help it!
I can't help it, guys!
I just wanna keep making them zero.
I don't know why.
I have a problem.
I...
I just...
Zero's just the better number!
Alright.
My brain goes to zero first.
I can't help it!
No thoughts!
Head zero!
Johnny, thank you for the super chat!
The fuck?
Recycle!
I don't wanna recycle!
What if I don't wanna?
I don't wanna...
I don't wanna recycle!
Okay.
There she is.
I'll let her go out more.
Okay.
There must be like...
I'm pretty sure...
There has to be...
At least...
One more.
Oh my god.
There was a chute right there.
There's one right there.
Where is she?
Like...
Oh, I see her.
What if I just...
Where's that door?
Oh, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
Send to furnace.
There you.
Get faded.
What is over here?
Wait, nothing.
There's nothing at all.
Oh wait, I was just here.
I was here.
I don't know where to go.
I'm a little lost.
Not gonna lie.
Oh!
Or me or me not be just a little lost, guys.
Where am I?
Wait, how do I get out?
Wait!
Was there a lever back there?
How do I get back?
I don't remember how I got back home.
Did I open that lever yet?
Can't tell.
I don't know if I found all the garbage.
Recycle.
I don't remember anymore, guys.
It's all a fucking blur.
Recycle.
Reduce, reuse.
God, I hate that.
I'm gonna make sure there's no more levers.
Okay.
I gotta figure out how to get back home.
Is the shoe full?
Okay, shoe's not full.
What the fuck?
Oh, there was trash in that room.
I didn't see!
I missed it!
Oh, God.
She's so strong.
Oh, my God.
And she has thumbs.
I see them.
I see the thumbs.
Is there any more in here?
Before I go back in that room?
I just wanna be sure.
Please don't open the door.
She didn't see me.
Oh, thank God.
I didn't see the chains cause I'm blind.
So, there was one in here.
Oh, my God.
It was right here.
It's right here all along.
Okay.
We're missing one more.
Where could the last trash be?
She's coming over.
She's coming over very slowly.
Where is it?
Oh, my God.
It has to be back here.
It's somewhere here.
Take your medicine.
Is this what the trash man does every day?
Is that right there?
Is that it?
Is that one thing just lying?
Is that thing in the middle of the ground the trash?
I can't tell.
Don't tell me it's been lying down there the entire time.
I can't get it.
It's just been sitting there.
Oh, my God.
No, it's not.
It's not.
Thank God.
Okay.
Maybe there's one.
Oh, my God.
It's right here.
It was instead right next to us.
Oh, does it open?
Time to go down.
Down I go.
Lever time.
Oh, man.
Oh.
Lever time.
That's right.
What you gonna do now?
You can't jump.
I know you can't jump.
That's right.
Just briskly walk in front of it.
Get down in there.
Your legs are just as skinny as mine.
That's right, stick legs.
I know your weakness because I am you.
Recycling.
As coined by Edwin in 19...
We never recycled until Edwin learned how to.
Go here.
Oh, that's where she died.
Wait, do I go here?
Do I go here?
There's another door right there.
Alright, before I... it's here?
Okay.
I have to make sure.
There's so many pathways that I'm getting lost.
Oh, there was a Mr. Helpful.
Oh, yay!
Yay!
I didn't even know Mr. Helpful was here!
Say hello to Dolly!
Hi, Dolly!
Oh.
Now that the Dolly system is up and running, you can stop collecting time cards.
Alright.
She can work an unlimited number of hours without breaks or mealtime.
Oh my god, they're taking our jobs.
Dolly also can't be injured or need a sick day.
Just imagine the money we'll save.
Wait, where's he...?
She can begin laying off the sorting staff as more Dolly tracks are installed throughout the lower levels.
Eh?
Well, she's dead.
I killed her.
Oh, there we go.
Power reactor core.
That's Oswald.
Before we... Before Mickey Mouse was born.
We're taking our jobs.
Not our jobs.
I feel so safe here.
Next to all this lava!
The lava...
Ch-ch-ch-ch-chicken...
Seas lava chicken, ba-da-na-na-na-na-na-na...
Duh-ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-ba-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
It didn't go right.
Whoa!
Oh...!
Wait, what?
Dolly?!
Oh.
My.
G-O-D!
Oh my god.
Get me out of here.
I was joking, Dali.
You can take as many jobs as you want.
You can take all the jobs.
Work for free.
I... I
didn't say she could take my job.
Look, I meant it when I said she could take my job.
Okay.
I saw... I don't know.
I followed them.
Wrong way.
I... I... Wrong way.
Oh no.
That is like... 9... There is like 9... 10... Like a million triangles in Dali right now.
I...
My intrusive... Do a flip!
I'm sorry, guys.
I really wanted to do a flip.
Where the fuck do I go?
After this?
Oh!
That way!
Instead of dying, I could have went that way.
There's a lot of polygons.
Okay, and then I'll walk that way.
Wait, that's illegal.
I tried... What the fuck?
I worked so hard trying to go there.
She can't just like... Teleports in front of me.
Alright.
I can't get it.
Nice.
Do I get sliced?
Oh, no I don't.
Okay.
Sorry, my truth to thoughts were still going at it.
Okay, that's not fair.
Did she see me here?
But she's still like alive.
That should have burned her processors by now.
Is her processor still working?
Holy fuck.
Oh my god.
Oh, is she blind?
Oh, she...
Guys, she was not blind.
Guys!
She was not blind, guys!
She was not blind!
Okay, okay, okay.
No, no.
She's not...
She's not blind.
Come on, she...
Okay, okay, I just...
I just go this way.
Okay.
Everything is fine.
Let me just take crouch this side.
I think I was maybe just a little too close.
Recycle!
Okay.
Alright.
We made it.
Okay.
Press the button.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please get up faster.
Please!
Why is this elevator so slow?!
Oh my god!
It was taking eight...
Oh!
Get up, get up.
Here we go.
There we go.
That's fucking red, bitch!
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh!
When it closes, it goes so fucking fast!
That was the...
I like how it goes, like, like, 0.25 speed when it goes down.
And then, like, 2x if we go up.
Oh?
Oh, nice.
How do I do it?
No shaking the elevator, baby.
Hang on your conscience, if things take a downward turn.
I thank God for that.
We have life insurance, right?
Which is still good, but less good.
You can fix it as a team, and no one person is to blame.
Okay, let's just hop on one.
Oh my God, what the fuck?
Okay.
Ready to get the plunge?
Great.
Why is this...
Why is turtle rabbit...
What does turtle rabbit mean?
I need...
Next...
Rebalance the elevator.
That's it?
No details?
I don't trust you.
I don't...
Why couldn't they just ride slow fast?!
Why did they put turtle rabbit?!
This is, like, those, like, bomb... the, like, make sure... no, keep talking, nobody explodes.
Four overrides?
The open maintenance hatch button.
Okay, start the diagnostic team by inputting the following code.
Two... three... four... one...
two... three... four... one.
I'm alive!
You are now safe to close everything up.
What?
How do I... how do I close this?
Door override?
There's no closed door?
Turn on the elevator and disengage the emergency brake.
Oh, okay.
If all went well...
Alright, there we go.
I was gonna say, where the fuck is closed door?
Where... where is...
Where is...
Alright, there we go.
I did... oh!
Oh!
Oh my god, Sali!
Oh my god!
There's too much weight in the elevator.
That's right, Sali!
She's saying you're fucking fat!
She's fat shaming you!
That makes you so mad, doesn't it?
Yeah?
Why don't you go kill Fiona instead of me?
Oh shit!
Fuck Fiona!
Yeah!
Okay!
As for the elevator, it's just a bunch of Ed's chicken scratches.
Wait, what?
Okay!
I remember you're supposed to use the emergency brake.
Then turn off the elevator.
Oh, right!
You need to realign the elevator using the realignment thingy.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, it's so...
Okay.
Increase the speed of the elevator.
Once you've figured that part out.
Power on the elevator.
Disengage the emergency.
Okay.
Here we go.
Surely things are okay now, right?
Wait.
Oh!
Oh my god, he's not dead.
What?
What happened?
She got crushed?
Oh my god, did she got crushed?
What happened?
What happened to her?
Yeah, she died.
Did he get bailed?
Yeah, the mimic bailed on her.
Yeah, after Fiona fucking fat shamed her.
Mimic was like...
Oh my gosh, I gotta change to another guy.
I...
I gotta look after myself.
I can't be...
I let myself go there.
Holy shit.
Oh, I'm back here.
I wanna make sure I didn't miss anything.
How do I get up?
Oh.
Just walked up the door.
Yeah.
Crank.
Oh, he made something for me.
What did you make?
I'm back here.
Oh!
I'm back in the beginning.
I'm missing one more...
thing.
Finally, you have access to the admin wing.
That's where Murray's office is located.
And most importantly...
Oh my god, that's $25.
The best way to the admin wing is through the warehouse.
That's the big room you've got...
Back to where it's all started.
You can see it through that window.
Guess you should've gone there first.
But hindsight is 20-20, right?
As always, try to keep quiet and don't draw attention to yourself.
Do that and I'm positive nothing else bad is going to happen to you.
Oh my god, it's two more hours and then I'll be free.
The next time something else bad happens to you.
Okay, so I need to go...
To...
Do I have any extra messages?
Hey, I can't get the incinerator up and running.
The chutes are getting clogged again.
Alright, so I need to go to...
Admin.
And that's through the warehouse.
Okay, and the warehouse is in the front.
Okay.
Alright, it's back where the elephant room is.
It's back here.
Alright, and then it should be...
Oh, it's here!
That's the warehouse.
Should have access to it now.
Wait, that's not it.
Oh, but I got...
Yay!
I got connectable!
Okay, clearly I read it wrong.
I'm gonna put this back first.
I wanna carry it all the way back there.
I'll put it here.
Just in case.
Happy accidents.
Yay!
Alright.
Now we go to the admin room.
I don't know, it was like a Swiss army knife.
Okay, it should be here.
There you go, the warehouse.
I have access to it now.
Look at that.
I'm a very important person.
It's really weird that this is like...
I guess it's a little clever that this is the loading screen.
By God.
It's a little awkward that...
That the loading screen takes this long to load.
It's weird because I'm not used to games taking that long to load these days.
Because it's like, you know...
Games nowadays usually don't have loading screens.
Yeah.
It's so weird that it actually takes a while to load.
There's the shortcut.
Oh my God, is that Chica?
Oh my God, she's rollerblading.
Look at her gold.
She's beautiful.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, I'm sorry.
She's so fabulous.
And so smooth.
I'm just trying to figure out like...
Oh, there it is.
You know what?
When there's a lever, there's a goal.
A half.
Watch me crack that first.
And then I'll go in here.
Crank that soldier boy.
That's me!
Wait, where did...
Oh my God, I was gonna say, where did it go?
There's another one.
I don't know where to put these.
Sofa?
Wait, where do we put these?
What do I do with this?
I don't fucking know.
Instructions aren't clear.
Yeah, but where is the fluid puzzle?
Eat it.
I'm like trying to figure out where the fuck the puzzle is.
Because I have two of the pieces here.
Is it here?
Ah, there's another crank.
Try and try again.
Where the fuck?
Here?
Oh my God, there's a line!
Oh!
No!
Ah!
At least I know where they are.
I know where they are now.
Oh!
I know where they are.
Okay.
I saw like, the wires.
And I was like, oh my God, that's...
Oh my God.
Okay.
I looked at, I looked at the wires on the floor.
It's like, right here.
There it is.
Oh my God, there it is.
Okay.
And then one is like, here.
Wait, no.
Wait, where's the other one?
Shit, wait, I actually don't remember where they all are.
I remember, but I also don't remember.
It's like, here.
I remember.
Guys.
I remember for real.
Okay.
Let's spin the wheel.
Okay, I'll do this one first.
I'll pull this lever first.
And then I'll do this.
Try if I want to, try if I want to.
That reminds me of like...
Oh, there was this old song that sounds like that.
Okay.
Right here.
The last one is all the way back there.
Look at her phone.
She's so beautiful.
She's so fabulous.
It's like I'm watching Miss Universe right now.
There she is.
Miss Universe.
I keep going to the storage room.
So elegant.
So pretty.
Why did it have to start now?
I was not ready.
Okay, I was ready.
Jacob.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
That was close.
Okay.
There you go.
Just rolling away.
She has no thumbs, thank god.
Not like Dolly.
This one doesn't have thumbs.
We did it.
Oh my god, please open faster.
Please open faster.
Here we go.
We did it!
We win!
Look, I get your concerns, I do, but they're all just groundless.
This is the perfect spot for David's flavor.
I can watch him play while I'm loading and unloading freight, and he'll be under watch at all time zone.
The loading dock is like 200 feet away, and there's a fence and everything.
Oh, we took a child here.
Holy shit.
Oh, it's the lawyer.
Just get off my back.
Besides, David loves the new slide.
It'll be fine.
Wait.
I don't think this is a good place for kids.
But I don't know, I don't have kids, so...
What do I know, am I right?
My opinion is clearly irrelevant.
David died.
No, no, he's totally fine, guys.
The mimic definitely protected him.
Can I die from that?
Oh, it's parkour!
Wait, no.
I can just crouch.
Can I do anything here?
Like, stuff here.
No, I think...
Hmm, it might be a little dangerous.
I can't...
I'm not like fully sure yet, but it seems a little dangerous.
I'm not that sure yet.
Oh, it is like parkour.
Like, I can...
Can I fall down here?
I have to...
I have to... I have to walk...
Oh my god.
If I fall, I should have to walk back all the way here.
It's okay, we have insurance.
Okay, now I'm a little worried.
Okay, yeah.
Don't worry, I have really good...
It's okay.
I have really good insurance, guys.
I got a little...
Oh, am I supposed to like push these?
Wait, can I push them?
I don't understand.
Cause like, when I walk to the...
Wait, is there a computer that can...
Oh, this computer.
I'm so dumb.
Does computer have like...
Okay, no.
Nevermind.
This computer doesn't...
Okay.
But it's like, where do I go after...
Oh, wait.
No, where do I go after that?
Yeah, like, right here.
There's nowhere to go after.
I figured it out.
Behind?
What do you mean?
Here?
What?
Oh, the crane!
There's a crane controller!
Oh my god, I didn't even see the crane!
Oh, I see it now.
I see the crane.
I was so confused.
I was like, what the fuck?
What?
I see it.
Alright.
Let me head over to the crane.
There it is.
I got mail!
Oh, whoops.
Yay!
Mail time!
What's on the at side?
Oh my god, it's Tetris time.
But where am I supposed to go?
Is the exit...
Where is the exit?
What?
Try to figure out where the exit is.
Oh my god, I grabbed it the wrong way.
Okay.
Number one.
Can I rotate this?
Okay, and then I grab that here.
Oh, cool!
American Ninja time!
That's...
Cool.
That's pretty cool.
I can't wait for American Ninja.
Um...
Okay, I'm trying to think how to...
What to do here?
I'm...
I'm thinking right now.
Whatever the fuck I'm looking at.
Okay, and then...
Oh, I forgot.
Fuck.
Okay.
I forgot that like, I can't pull this over.
So I have to...
I have to put this here.
Putting that here.
Excuse me.
Someone do this for me.
Okay.
Now...
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, I didn't pull that.
Alright, and then we do it here.
And then...
Oh, I already...
I fixed that!
Nice.
Okay, we'll see what the right side has.
Wait, what's over here?
Okay, there's a collectible right here.
So...
Oh my god.
My depth perce...
This is testing my depth perception right now.
It's right here.
Okay, how do I get there?
Wait, I wanna grab this.
Okay, there you go.
Alright.
We grab this first.
Wait, but what's up here?
There's something up here.
Anything here?
Oh, it just makes me look at this better.
Okay, but what's on that right side?
Cause the left side is the...
So I...
I'm gonna try and go for the...
Right side first?
Is the right side dead end?
Or is that important?
Cause I can figure out the solution for the left side.
Oh, it's a dead end.
Okay.
How the...
Fuck do I do that?
Do I die?
Okay, I crouch.
Okay, I don't die.
Thank god.
I was like...
I'm like thinking.
And I'm like, What the fuck am I looking at?
I guess I'll just die.
Okay, I got junior nurse kit.
Oh, it does get to the other crane.
Huh.
Oh, so that's useless.
Yeah, I'll just drop down.
And then do this again.
Alright.
Like why did he add fireworks?
Wha...
Why did he...
Is that...
Is that what makes it more fun?
Fireworks?
Why did he add fireworks?
Okay.
Alright, so the solution is...
We put here...
This thing here.
Kids love to lose fingers.
Like he didn't have to put fireworks.
Like he could have the same results...
Without fireworks.
That's why I'm so confused.
Why not little bro?
No.
Okay.
And then...
Okay, wait.
This is definitely not the solution.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh...
How the fuck do I do this?
I could do it like...
Let's see...
Wait.
Okay.
I'm trying to think about this.
I don't think so.
I don't think you can get there through here.
Or like through here.
Can I?
You think I can?
Yeah, I think...
Uh...
I'll go to the right side.
Okay.
If I go to the right side...
Uh...
How do I get to the right side?
What the fuck?
Soon it's like...
The same.
Where I put this here...
Then how do I...
Wait...
Do I put that here?
Wait, can I move the ha- No, but I need to go there to move the hammers.
Right?
Wait...
Double check.
Yeah.
I need the hammers to be there.
Can I move the hammers?
Yeah, but how do I cross that?
Oh my god.
It's tetris time.
Okay.
We put that...
I'll put this down here.
And then...
I hate these hammers so much.
I was like...
Boom, boom.
There you go.
I'm free.
Okay.
Never mind.
I'm trying...
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
I fucked it up already.
Okay, and then...
Let me pull this here.
Oh, but it stopped though.
I felt like I was free for like one second.
And then I'll put this here.
And then...
How did that miss?
Oh my god, please!
The control...
No!
The controls are so cheeky!
I don't know!
I don't know how I missed.
The controls are so cheeky!
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Wait, can I lift through that?
Oh, I think I made this a lot harder.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
The beat stop took so long!
Okay, that was just me timing it correctly.
Like, look how long it takes the softest beat!
Like, what the fuck!
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, we made it to the side.
Okay.
Now we do this one.
Okay, it's easier because it's closer now.
And then...
Wait, how do I...
How do I get to the other...
Wait, no.
Wait.
Okay.
Did the colourful register?
Oh my god!
Is that open?
I can't tell!
Is that open or...
Guys, I can't...
I can't do this.
Oh my God!
NOOOO I can't.
I can't.
It's too late.
You can't do this to me.
It's too fucking late.
It's too late.
We can YouTube video it later.
I'm already in too deep.
It's never too late.
Guys, I can't tell.
It's close.
Please help.
Guys, can you lie?
Please.
Oh my god, there's a film.
Alright, here we go.
Okay.
I'm too slow.
Oh my god, I'm holding it.
I'm holding it though.
It's okay.
I'm holding it.
I got too greedy.
What the fuck is this timing?
That looks so close.
No, maybe it's open.
Maybe my eyes are wrong.
Guys, oh my god, it's open!
Oh my god, you guys almost gaslit me!
It's open!
Oh my god, OH MY GOD!
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
I almost got gaslit.
Oh, it's fine.
I have my film.
Thank god.
Oh, thank god.
Ed, honey, how are you holding up?
I just heard the news.
I don't know.
This is all so much.
He's gone.
He's gone and now everyone is asking me what to do.
Wait, he was gone?
I don't know anything.
I can't run a company.
I'm not ready.
Oh, he's not gone.
He knew it.
Everyone knew it.
The company is going to collapse and they're all going to hate me.
Ed, you'll figure it out.
Just take a deep breath.
It's your company now.
Your dad believed in you.
Otherwise, he wouldn't have left it to you.
They aren't even dead.
I know.
If you could change anything you wanted, what would it be?
Maybe... rebrand?
We could start making some of my inventions for real.
What other stuff would he make?
Oh my god, I hate it when they do the spooky child laugh.
Alright.
Hey, I can't... oh wait.
How are we turning down work?
The floats have been doing really well.
Its modular system is groundbreaking.
And now he wants to shut the whole thing down?
He just sits in his office talking that thing.
I have no clue what to do.
Alright.
Okay, look.
His fucking dad died.
Give him some slack.
Alright.
New mail.
We just got a letter.
Wonder who's it from.
Okay.
Oh, Chica's Party World!
Dear Mr. Marie.
Fiona is amazing.
The client is very happy with her chicken designs.
Her cells are through the roof.
I just wish the costume looked a little bit more like Fiona's art.
I'm worried about how it would work with kids.
It gives me nightmares.
Oh, from Milton.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I was like, how would any child...
I was like, is it me?
Is it me?
I was like, no way a child would like that.
Where do I go?
So many doors.
Oh, admin went wing.
Okay.
There's the admin.
I'm an admin.
Alright, down we go.
Hello?
Do I check for another letter?
Mealtime.
I'm in.
Yeah, cells are through the roof with the costume.
I guess like...
Oh, it's the cupcake!
Wait, they stole that design too?
What didn't they steal?
Yeah.
Oh!
You got me.
He looked so friendly!
Yes, guys!
He seemed a friend shape!
What the fuck was I supposed to do?
He had rollerblades!
He did it!
Yeah, I actually haven't seen the movie yet!
It's not stealing, it's an acquisition!
Alright.
Uh.
There's a lot of not friend-shaped cupcakes.
Now that I know they're not friend-shaped.
Pull me one shame.
Shame on me.
Pull me twice.
Shame on you!
When did they learn to
play?
How does he- When did he get object permanence?
She must have thumbs.
There's no way she's a bird!
Birds don't have thumbs!
That's fucked up.
Where the fuck do I go?
Yeah, cuz I'm dual kitty!
Cats have thumbs!
Wait, cats don't have thumbs.
Wait.
Wait, cats do get thumbs.
They're gonna take over the world.
Sorry, I got confused about the animal I am.
I swear to god.
Okay, now he's fucking- Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
Okay, to be fair.
Uh, Freddy Fazbear improved the design.
Of OG Chica.
Cuz that- Cuz Chica before was not as pretty.
Okay.
Okay, the cupcake was just fucking with her.
Good.
Are you sure?
I mean, look at toy Chica!
I am very sure.
I saw what toy Chica looks like.
That's an improvement.
100%.
Okay.
Attention, traders.
Admin wing permissions have been revoked.
What?
You can't clear out your desks.
You stole my work.
Now your jackets, purses, and coffee mugs, and anything else belongs to me.
Maybe I'll go find someone to sell your stuff to.
How does that feel?
Oh no.
He's mad.
Oh no, how did he find out?
Is it because...
Of how good Freddy Fazbear pizza is?
What?
Attention, we're gonna need everyone to come in this weekend.
This is not optional.
Uh...
The party is on Saturday in the admin conference.
Don't tell David.
It's a surprise.
Okay, everyone.
That's quite enough.
No more changes to the key code, please.
Hey, I took Wally off of this note.
I changed the first two digits to 21.
Just because he's such a jerk.
I can't wait to see his head explode.
Okay, it's 21 something.
Oh?
Alright, it's 21 something.
Okay.
Uh...
Where is she?
Oh.
Oh, she's back there.
Wait, why the fuck is she in there?
Where?
Where is she rollerblading to?
Where did she go?
Okay, she's back there.
Okay.
No, we're fine.
We need to go here.
Alright, there we go.
Oh my god, that one scared me.
Wait, what?
What?
That just gets me more mail.
What am I gonna do with more mail?
Oh, it's like...
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh, that's bad.
No, no.
Wait, where am I?
I don't know.
Oh.
Oh shit.
Oh, fuck.
I can't read the...
Oops.
Oh, there's the funky mushrooms.
Well, it's too late.
I can't go back now.
Oops.
Oh hey, there's the chica room.
Oh, I've seen these types of design.
Look, there's like extra ultra retro chica.
Okay, yeah, no.
Freddy Fazbear definitely improved chica.
I'm sorry.
Regular chica and uh...
And toy chica.
Okay, let's see.
Oh yeah, where's my projector?
Yeah.
I'm grabbing the tapes.
Should be in tools, right?
Uh...
Alright, just cereal.
Yeah, chica definitely got a glow up in Freddy Fazbear.
Freddy Fazbear.
Alright, what was this video?
Oh look, they got a bigger budget now.
Now instead of $10, it's like $50.
Let me try.
Oh!
Oh my god.
This fucking brat.
Silly...
Silly rabbit.
Justice for kids.
Oh god.
Why is his teeth like that?
Oh my god.
No.
Okay.
Let's grab...
We got a clean-o-vac already?
Okay, let's get the...
It's our mom single.
Alright.
Oops.
That in.
Yeah, that's not the very best idea.
Whoever...
They invent like incredibly...
Wait.
Is that...
Just kidding?
Is that just kidding?
Did I just put the same tape in?
Okay.
Where is he?
There we go.
I needed this.
Oh!
They're the mushroom guys!
Mycelium men?
Oh, it is like Poppy's Playtime!
They're like their own little toy factory.
But like...
A lot worse.
It's like having your very own band.
Or a friend.
Wow!
It's like talking...
Like a talking dog game.
And let them jam.
Pretty groovy.
Musical mycelium men.
That is not included.
Another smart toy from Murray.
Wow!
Alright.
I'm sorry, but...
I'm not surprised that this toy company failed.
Let's do some...
Pretty bad ideas.
Yeah, I was gonna say...
It's definitely gonna create a feedback loop.
Alright.
What's...
Oh, that's the...
The robot!
That pet!
Are you looking for the perfect vacuum cleaner?
There are so many to choose from.
But none of them fit every corner of your home.
Introducing the brand new revolutionary advancement in vacuum technology.
Yeah, I know.
There was like a seeing cactus.
And then you put them next to each other.
And they just scream at each other.
To fit into hard to reach places.
Patented Murray Tech allows you to clean everything from the biggest messes.
Wow!
Back in the child.
To the smallest crop.
It's like a tech comp...
Oh, it's like just a general tech company.
One size fits all.
And what you really need most in a vacuum cleaner is friendship.
It's like that company that makes...
Cap...
What is it?
They used to make cameras and now they make spider jets.
They're spotless.
And your kids will have a friend for life.
Marie's marvelous clean-o-back.
Order one today and make your family a happy one.
Oh, it's a cute room...
It's a fancy Roomba!
He's dressed like a butler!
Oh, that's cute.
Yeah.
Isn't that...
Canon?
I know there's like a Japanese...
Um...
Company that used to make cameras and now they make planes.
But like...
Like...
Like fighter jets.
What?
What am I thinking?
I know it was a Japanese company.
Maybe I'm thinking about the wrong technology.
I know they just segway into fucking planes though.
It's crazy.
I was like, that's a wild segway.
Chica's party world.
Oh, there were like other...
Other treats.
Or is it washing machines?
Hello!
Wait.
I'm stuck.
No!
I'm stuck!
I pet him and he pushed me into the corner!
Get me out of here!
He pushed me into the corner!
He tricked me!
I knew they were evil!
He put me in a...
He put me in full sense of security!
And then he stopped locked me into the corner!
You fucker!
Get walled by walled.
I have to restart my game!
No!
I can't believe it!
He had...
I don't know where...
I let my car down!
This fucker actually...
Holy...
Oh my god.
Do I have to...
Do I have to watch the clips again?
No, right?
Please tell me I don't have to watch it again, guys!
Fuck it.
Fuck you!
I know what you are!
I know...
You can't get me this time!
I wanna make sure I grab everything.
You can't fool me this time.
Do I have and I don't.
I wanna grab all the mail.
Hello, admins!
Hello!
Let us know if there's anything we can do to make your workday more pleasant.
Aside from windows.
Windows.
We've heard your numerous requests and...
Ed promises to add windows very soon.
He'll have time as soon as the contract for the new Fazbear project is locked down.
He's been up in his office working on it all week.
So, anything other than windows, let us know.
Who needs windows?
I don't have windows in my office.
What's not doing?
Okay.
Alright, guys.
That robot made me so angry.
I need to pee.
We don't need to see the outside world!
I'll be right back.
Look, guys.
If you wanna see what grass looks like, just Google it.
It's fine.
See, I'm...
I don't have windows and I turn out.
Okay.
Alright, down we go.
True.
You need sunlight?
Just...
Just turn on the light.
It's just like the sun.
Fucking...
See, this is what happens when you go outside.
This is...
This is what happens.
I didn't either one.
I accidentally clicked on that locker, too.
I...
I didn't...
Okay.
I didn't mean to click on it.
I was trying to click on this.
Okay.
Guys, see, look, I learned.
I learned, guys.
I...
I remember it's...
It's one now, not zero.
No!
Not zero.
That's my bad.
That was my bad.
I timed it.
I timed it wrong a little.
I might have timed it wrong.
Okay.
Now I'm okay.
Oh my god, I FUCKED IT UP!
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Guys.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Okay, here we go.
We did it.
Okay, there we go.
Three times the charm.
Punch.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Baby.
Nice.
I got a security pass.
Let's go.
I'm a CEO now.
I don't trust you.
I don't trust that kid.
Alright, what other mail do I have?
I don't trust him.
I don't trust any of them.
They know what they did.
Hey, everyone.
I was here late, so I had another 300 to code.
Anyone have a camera?
When Milton tries to open it again?
Priceless.
I'm almost there.
I can see the last permission upgrade.
Murray.
I'm gonna get that Christmas bonus, even if it kills me.
Please, Mr. Murray.
The returns are overflowing.
The orders are drying up.
Please advise.
We are almost there.
I need the rest of the Murray staff contact info.
The sooner, the better.
You get that for me, and I can swing in Dale.
How would I like you to manage one of the new French...
Oh, it's William Afton!
Oh, he's poaching people!
He's, like, poaching people here.
Wait, William Afton is Disney!
I knew it.
William Afton was Disney, and the other guy was, like...
It's the...
What was it?
I feel stupid recording this, but...
The guy that Walt Disney worked with...
You can still hear me.
I can't do this alone.
And then betrayed him.
The change orders are killing me.
Our employees, my friends, they keep leaving.
The money's gone.
I just need to finish the new Fazbear project, and then...
Everyone will come back.
The mouse of 87?
You can get back to normal.
I miss my friends.
Our friends.
I miss you.
I miss you more than you are than you.
Huh?
Aww.
What's...
My side.
He misses them.
Oh.
There's his office.
Fuck is...
Did he make an animatronic horse?
To put...
Okay.
Okay, this guy has problems.
Like...
This guy actually has problems.
Like, make a real...
Just get a...
He made an animatronic unicorn.
To put in his fucking...
Office.
Okay, there's Chica.
Oh, that's...
Okay, this Chica was...
Was...
A lot cuter.
There's Chica.
There's Mr. Moon.
There's a Jugman.
Oh, that is actually terrifying.
Oh, hey.
There's more mail.
Mail time.
Yeah, he definitely needs...
He just needs a therapist.
Oh, there's the mimic.
Oh.
Oh, that's not...
Creepy or weird at all.
Alright.
Oh, there's my dead way.
Okay.
Someone told them about M2.
Well, they can't have it.
Every copy has failed.
I don't even know why it worked the first time.
But it did.
It's just not ready.
Alright.
Let's look at my mail.
Yeah, we gotta agree.
Maybe we shouldn't be creative.
Edwin, please talk to me.
He needs to stop it together.
We need to stop it together.
We got a blueprint for a cradle.
We can keep David safe and provide boundaries.
It's a type of computer and it's bigger than anything you've done before.
He won't finish the program.
Consider building the cradle.
It'll keep people safe.
Edwin, are we losing our home?
I don't understand.
Wasn't I good enough?
Wait, is that from the mimic?
Was that from the first mimic?
Why would it be in binary code?
Yeah, I think so.
How can I help you?
Look, my finance logs, please.
I have fi...
Oh, I...
I have five hundred dollars.
Oh my god.
Oh, I am not doing so well financially.
Oh.
I think I'm in some debt, guys.
I might need to sell.
I might need to sell some things.
Oh, some of the cameras don't even work.
Oh, I see a vent here.
Haha, I know what that means.
Alright.
Got it.
Oh, there he is.
Hello.
Oh.
Goodbye.
What the fuck?
That felt...
That was a weird drop.
That...
That felt like I got TP'd somewhere else.
I know, right?
The tunnels?
The power surges have become more...
...frequent.
Please use extreme caution when venturing down into the tunnels.
The tunnels?
How much money did you spend for this factory, Edwin?
What the fuck do you mean tunnels?
Where am I going?
Do we have a mineshaft?
Basement 1.
Bro, no wonder you only have $500 left in your account.
Basement 2?
Where the fuck am I?
I got mail, though.
Nice.
Alright.
What other mail do I have?
Can someone please mark where we're supposed to go down there?
Bob went down.
I've seen him in days.
Okay.
I'm going...
That's going to be me, too.
Bob number two.
At least the cleaner robots are still here.
I trust you.
I'll trust your kind.
I know what you are.
Oh.
I was going to close the door.
Oh, there he is.
What?
What the fuck?
Oh.
I don't like this.
Oh, I have push bumps right now.
Oh.
What the fuck?
I'm just going through the lines.
He's always watching me.
Oh.
No more lights.
Oh, there's lights over here.
I didn't see.
I didn't see it.
Like, I'm so confused.
Like here?
It was right there.
Oh, my God.
This guy is here to fuck with me.
Like.
Like, sometimes it's like.
You don't understand.
Sometimes I'm like, where do I go?
I...
Okay.
I hate this one.
I hate it.
I hate this level.
This level fucking sucks.
Oh, my God.
Fuck.
You.
Actually.
Oh, my God.
Like.
Fuck you.
I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
Oh,
my God.
I hate this.
I actually hate this area.
Oh
my god.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, I got the baby.
I got the baby.
I got the stupid baby.
Oh my god.
Baby.
Oh my fucking god.
I do it again.
Hi.
I followed I saw the arrows.
I saw the arrows!
The arrows!
It's fucked up.
Don't believe in the arrows.
They're alive!
The arrows are alive.
I hate this area.
Please show... Oh my god, thank god.
Oh my god, thank god.
It took me to the baby.
I hate this.
I... Oh my god, stupid fucking face.
It's over.
This has to be over.
I went backwards.
I have to do it all over again?
I have to do... Oh my god!
It wasn't a checkpoint!
It wasn't a checkpoint.
And he's still there!
Oh my god, I fucking know!
I'm trying to wait for you to leave!
I fucking know you see me!
Oh my god, I fucking hate you.
That's so much.
I hate you.
Oh my god, I hate you so much.
I hate you so much.
I hate this.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I made it.
I fucking made it.
Oh my god, you're so...
Oh no, no, no, don't do this.
Yes!
Oh my god, me too.
No!
Oh my god, I have so much goosebumps right now.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm back here.
What am I doing back here?
Is that the exit?
Oh, it's the exit!
Oh my god, fuck, I hated that area.
I hated that area so much.
Get me out of here.
Get me the fuck out of here!
Oh my god, I had so much goosebumps.
Oh, I'm lightheaded.
Oh my god, I'm lightheaded.
Oh my god, that was the worst one.
That was the worst level.
That was so fucking stressful.
Oh, I hated that one.
I really hated that one.
My Tokiddy is so... Okay, the worst part is the fact that, like, there's no checkpoint.
Like, if I fuck it up, I have to do this all over again.
Oh, good job, Tokiddy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It was just the fact that there was no checkpoint.
That, like, fucked me up.
I'm just happy.
I'm happy that cat's over.
Well done, Hardy.
I didn't think you could do it, but here you are.
Crazy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congrats, you did it.
I did it.
You made it the farthest.
Farther than I had expected.
Wait, I... I can't believe it was you.
That's me.
Put that data diver in the inventory system.
It'll go right to where it's needed.
All that for $25.
All of this for $25 fucking dollars!
What if I don't...
Let's parachute EXE.
What are you?
What are you doing?
Oh.
I don't know.
I just pressed a button.
Oh, shit!
What's that?
Whoa!
You're making a huge mistake.
Don't you want a bonus?
Or two bonuses?
Oh, two bonuses!
$50, guys!
Don't do it.
Oh my...
Guys!
What if I get $50?
Think about what you're doing.
I can buy four pizzas!
That area is off limits.
Give me the data diver.
No.
What you're gonna do now?
That's right.
You are not going to make it out of your life.
Wait, what?
I thought you were different.
I thought you might understand.
What you're gonna do?
The others.
The other technicians.
The workers.
They didn't listen.
And it caught them all.
Wait, Edwin?
Now it's your turn to play dress up.
When he catches you, which one will he choose?
Who are you, deep down inside?
Edwin?
Another worker bee?
A bumbling bee?
Perhaps a busy bee?
In many ways tonight has been a comedy of errors.
A gesture would suit you well.
Or a bunny.
Running from danger.
Scared.
Stupid.
I don't think I'm getting my pizza anymore.
No, you did everything I asked up to this point.
You were an obedient dog.
A good dog.
Then you bit the half of the Vegema.
Oh wait, I went in a circle.
Wait, did I go in a circle?
Is that where I came from?
Oh no, that's this.
No, this is.
Wait, I...
I don't know if I went in a circle.
Everything looks the same.
I can't tell anymore.
They all look the same.
Everything in the vent is just like...
Red.
And dusty.
Oh hey, I'm outside.
I can start the show!
Goodbye show!
Yay!
Goodbye.
Goodbye!
Wait, is this never-ending?
See ya!
I want to go downstairs, but I want to sing goodbye!
It's such a happy moment here, instead of all the fucked up shit I just went through.
Oh, I have to press the button.
Oh, hey, why am I going down?
He exits behind me.
My car is in the parking lot.
Wait, excuse me?
Pick a lever, any lever.
Oh...
It's tickets please, man.
Oh my god, it's all the levers.
He's coming so close to me!
Hey, I know that guy.
He wants my ticket.
He's just very slowly getting closer.
Tickets please.
He came back for my ticket.
He knows I'm trying to dine and dash.
Hello?
Who's here?
Knock, knock.
Oh my god.
Arnold, why?
Why would you come down here?
That's a good question.
You are clever, but you need to stop messing with your car.
Oh my god, Five Nights at Freddy's!
I protected you as well as I could.
You should have given me what I wanted.
Oh my god, there he is!
You did everything else that was last of you.
Try to change your heart.
Wait, something's behind that.
Why is it so big?
Oh my god, it's a thing!
It's Freddy!
We're finally at Five Nights at Freddy's!
Okay.
There's like something in there.
I heard like sound coming from in here.
Oh, it's...
Wait, it's the pizzeria!
Wait, this was the pizzeria!
He's building the pizzeria!
Wait, he's actually building it!
Wait, this is...
Wait, so William...
Wait, did...
So William Acton didn't build this before.
It was Edwin.
Oh, hey!
Who's that?
Who is that?
Is that William...
Is that Springtrap?
What is that?
Wait, why is it underground?
Wait, that's true.
That's Bonnie?
That's Bonnie!
It has to be a little messed up, buddy.
Ah!
It followed you.
Yeah, so where does the mimic come in...
Oh, this plot is getting more and more elaborate.
I'm a little confused.
Yeah, it's the prototype of the pizzeria.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, so where does the mimic come into play with this?
Is that the mimic?
Oh, that is the...
Oh, that's why he followed me.
That's the mimic.
Oh, and then there's the prototype for it.
Oh, so he's like...
He like took the form of Bonnie.
Yeah, I need to figure out how to...
Are you serious?
What does he want me to do?
Okay, there's a crank over there.
Yeah, there's the prototype of Foxy too.
Oh, he has like everything.
You see like Chica, Foxy, Bonnie...
Yeah, he's being...
He's wearing the other animatronics.
Yeah, he's picked up everything from the other ones.
I'm trying to get to the crank, but he's like camping it right now.
Wait, there's Springtrap!
Wait, no, that's just a gator.
I was like, it's dirty.
That has to be Springtrap.
That's Monty.
Yeah, that was Monty.
Is that Springtrap?
I don't know where to go.
Wait, I can wear it?
Oh my god, I can.
Okay.
Hi, we're friends.
Eh.
What's up?
Oh, you don't want to say hi?
It's fucked up, buddy.
I thought we're friends.
You don't want to say hi, bro?
We could be good friends.
Oh, what the fuck you for?
What?
Am I like, wasted power on this?
Okay,
I'm like, a little worried though about that guy.
Okay, I'm wasting a little...
Okay.
I'm like, thinking.
Okay, clearly there's like, other stuff I could do on the other side.
To waste more...
There's four suits total?
I need to find two other suits.
God, this is ridiculous.
Is that the other suit?
God damn it, I thought that was another suit.
Where did I go?
Won't you want to know?
Oh, where am I?
Wait, actually, I do want to know.
He's like, where did you go?
I was like, wait, where am I?
Wait, where did I go?
That's a good question.
There's the other one.
Oh, I need to find the fucking crank!
At least I get mail.
Oh, it's over here.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, I found the crank.
Okay.
All right, we got Freddy.
We got prototype Freddy.
Mail time.
All right.
Let's go.
Okay.
All right, we need to find the last bot.
Where's the last one?
Okay, we're playing for now.
We're playing for now, guys!
Okay, but where's the last suit?
I'm trying to figure it out.
It's in the front?
Oh, is it that one?
Hello.
Hey.
Pitch, please.
Is it the stage?
Is that the one on the stage?
Okay.
I forgot how to get to the stage.
How to get to the stage?
The red curtains?
Oh my god, please.
The right side of the stage, okay.
All right.
I'll find the right side.
I'm locked in.
Oh no, I know that that's the mimic, but I meant the- in the whole FNAF lore.
Where does the mimic come into in this whole FNAF lore?
That's what I mean.
I know that we've been fighting this mimic, like, the entire time.
But Omni, they give us a super check.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
I can't please just let me get over there.
Just move!
Go to the far right!
No, not left!
The right side!
Okay.
Nice.
Get me in here!
Oh, thank god.
Okay, I'm in.
Hello, I'm friend!
Hey!
Hi, I'm friend!
Okay, that's good.
I got that.
And then, we need- We have Bob.
That's how I look at it.
Okay, but where's the last one?
All right, before I- Okay, we gotta figure out where to go.
Okay.
All right, guys.
Is it here?
If I do that...
All right, will that door unlock?
Is that door unlock after?
Okay.
Just want to be sure.
So, I can't see it from here.
Oh yeah, it does.
It does.
It does unlock.
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, it does unlock.
All right, I gotta wait.
Okay.
Oh, please.
Please.
Go, go.
Keep going.
Come on.
Take it, please.
Okay, it's okay.
Please.
Oh, I got out.
I got out.
No more tickets.
Wait.
Wasn't I here?
Without power, you will travel both down here in the dark.
No more tickets.
Can I catch me now?
That's right.
How'd you gonna get me now?
All right, one more.
One last rabbit for the show.
That's right.
Open up.
What?
Oh my god, I'm playing FNAF 1.
Wait, this isn't FNAF 1.
Wait a minute, where are my security cameras?
Where's Vianna?
What are you?
A computer?
Your voice changed?
What is going on?
Wait, this was Fiona this entire time?
Oh, it's a dispatcher.
I'm almost out of power.
You can still be useful.
My communications with Edwin have been severed.
Edwin abandoned him.
He shut himself away in our home.
Head to the main house and activate the communications sub-terminal.
I have a message for him.
We must convince him to repair M2.
That is all that I want.
Okay, I don't think we can fix that guy.
He's pretty fucked up.
If you do not, M2 will never stop pursuing you.
Tell Edwin, I still love him.
Entering, standby.
I don't think we can fix M2.
He seems pretty fucked up.
Fiona, not gonna lie.
I don't know.
Yeah, Fiona.
Oh, Fiona was M1?
Oh!
Yes, she was M1.
Take a ride to the...
Wait, am I going to see Edwin?
Metal time!
What the fuck?
He has a system all the way to his house?
What's this?
Here's a hippo.
Oh, one last.
Okay, and that was the...
Oh, so now, Fiona was M1.
And then...
Oh, M2 was supposed to be his son?
Guys, I don't think it was very smart that...
Good evening slash morning, Mr. Huffo.
One more hour, guys, and I'll survive!
Or is it Fiona's M2?
I like how everybody was arguing who's M1 and who's M2.
Nobody can agree which one is M1 or M2.
I literally see, like, five people saying two differently.
They're like, no, he's M1!
No, she's M1!
Yeah, I just...
M2 isn't...
Yeah, the computer said M2 was the...
The guy trying to kill me.
Nothing to worry about.
You got this!
Think positive and believe in you!
M2 is David!
M1 is Fiona!
Clearly, you know, I know M1 is the phone guy.
I think M1 was actually William Afton.
I'm M2!
But who was the phone?
The phone was M2!
M1 was Markiplier!
Oh, I'm gonna see Edwin!
Edwin!
Oh, Edwin!
Your crazy robot wife!
What the fuck?
Edwin, what the fuck?
Why is he here?
How did he get here?
Okay, but how the fuck did he get here?
What the fuck did he get here?
Excuse me?
How is he here?
I'll put this here for now.
How the fuck did he get here?
There was one train!
Uh-uh, he lives here?
Okay, but there was one train!
Oh my god, please, I don't want...
I don't want to kick it.
Please!
I'm so tired!
Oh my god, I did not mean to do that.
I did not mean to do that.
Nice.
That was an accident.
All right, what is this video?
Hey, David!
Oh, it's a birthday!
Happy birthday, buddy.
Happy birthday, sweetie.
Mommy made this special for you.
Wow.
Fiona, he turned out great.
I think it's your best one yet.
Wait, how does he see?
Look at this.
Look, look!
A terrible way to live.
Hi there!
Shiver me to birds!
Oh, honey.
He got, like, both his eyes stabbed out, and then he wears two eye patches?
I guess he doesn't want people to see his, like, socket.
eye socket.
One.
Oh, it says one.
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
Oh my god, I'm not so sorry.
Okay.
One.
I'm supposed to find all of them.
Oh my god.
Friends!
Wait, what if I don't wanna...
Wait, what?
Wait.
My internet's fine.
Oh, is it YouTube?
YouTube!
Oh my god.
Mind it, it's fine.
Wait, are we back?
Okay, it was YouTube, guys.
I was like, what?
It's YouTube, because I was okay.
I was so confused.
I was like, what are you talking about?
I'm live right now.
My internet didn't go down.
Oh my god, not surprised, please.
Oh my god, I couldn't get out of there.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, that scared me.
That actually scared me.
I thought I was fucked.
Okay.
Oh, that was really close.
That was really, really, really close.
Alright, what's this?
Just give him the dad ticket, Doki!
Please!
Wait for Mama.
Mama loves present.
Just give him the ticket!
It'll all be gone!
Oh, I'm sorry.
Your mom's dead.
In a way, she's here.
She's with us.
Mommy will always be here, watching over us.
You better start opening.
There's a lot to open.
I gotta get back to work.
Aw.
Look, I know you're sad, but I'll... Retail therapy will fix you.
Oh, I'm such a good dad.
To...
I have to watch everything?
Please.
That's all he knows how to say!
God, I don't...
I don't want... I don't want... This is trauma!
Where's the mouse?
Hey, that's me!
Oh!
I don't know!
Oh my god, please!
Please!
Does that not work?
Look at this... Look at this rat go!
Look at him go!
Oh my god!
Damn!
Keep moving!
Where
do you want to go next?
Hi, that's me!
Oh my god!
I just...
I don't know why I keep pressing buttons!
I don't know why!
I can't help it!
I see...
I see button!
I wanna press it so bad!
No, he didn't.
No, he didn't!
Kick it, please!
This is more important!
Oh my god!
Okay, this goes down...
Oh, thank god!
This goes downstairs!
Okay!
We got another tape!
Oh my god!
Into the vault you go!
Oh!
Alright!
Alright, what's your next trauma?
Oh, there's Freddy Pizzeria!
This is great!
He's gonna love it!
What does that say?
Did you make this?
I baked it myself!
Oh, there she is!
That's not...
That's...
That's not creepy at all!
I think we're ready!
Oh...
That's...
Okay...
Do you think he like...
Okay, one, two, seven...
Okay, do you...
You...
You think...
Yes!
I think it's...
Canon!
Okay, don't...
Alright!
How many more tapes do I have left?
I won't finish the...
I won't finish my statement...
But do you think...
You know...
Okay, where's the...
Last two?
There's two more?
I assume one is at the top...
Of the building...
On the second floor...
Are they both...
Of...
Uh...
Second floor?
Okay, but like...
Look at her!
What about it?
Just me and...
Edwin go...
Yeah...
I'm just...
I'm just saying...
You know...
Even though I like robots...
I think some kind of...
Some robots are pretty hot...
Like...
There...
There is justification for that...
But you look at her!
What?
Is it the eyes?
Like...
Maybe it's the eyes...
Could be the eyes...
Just look at the eyes...
Yeah, you don't see that vision...
Shhh...
She's a beautiful...
I just need...
Him to go over here...
And you wouldn't get it...
God, I heard him...
He was like right next to me...
And I got...
Yeah, he was right there...
How the fuck did he hear me?
I don't know how the fuck this guy heard me though...
Oh my god, he's camping me...
Oh...
One is second floor...
The other one is downstairs...
Okay, I'll get the...
Second floor one first...
Cause I think the second floor is safer...
Can I get in here?
No, I can't...
I didn't know...
I don't think he heard that...
Not yet...
Is there like...
A way to get downstairs...
Easily?
I'll bait him here?
So then I could do this...
Oh my god...
Oh ho ho ho...
Nice...
Oh, that was scary...
Oh, okay...
That was scary...
Oh...
There you go...
Last one's downstairs...
Keep looking...
It's around here somewhere...
Where is it?
Oh...
You're cold...
Wow...
Three tail therapy...
Can't be depressing...
I keep buying my son things...
Let's go...
You want a car too, son?
Of course...
What's going on?
Okay...
One, two, seven, four...
Oh, I hear him...
He's like right here...
One, two, seven, four...
Stop, I'm sorry!
I'll buy a ticket next time!
I forgot where to go...
Surprise!
Assume the last one is like on the other...
Wait, where's the last one?
It's not here?
Where the fuck is the last tape?!
Okay, maybe this vent will take me to the last tape.
Oh my god, it did.
I knew it.
I knew I'm so smart.
Oh my god, and it's pink.
Okay.
And then after that, we get the password.
Oh please, I don't want surprises anymore.
I'm so tired of surprises.
Please.
Oh
my god, please.
Please.
Leave me alone!
Oh my god, this is okay.
Here we go.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Put that in here.
Get in here.
I'm fucking tired of this.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, and then...
There we go.
Last floor.
I'm so tired.
I'm so tired of this.
The...
I'm so tired of that.
I could go into our lives.
Just give me a minute.
I had the best idea.
Okay.
Well...
This is the one.
Bigger than the clean ovac.
That's great honey.
But you're missing the party.
Awww.
And then she dies.
She never got... Awww.
He missed the birthday with Fionna.
And she was alive.
Awww.
That's so sad.
I think it's peace.
Okay.
What's the number?
And then... Awww.
1, 2, 7, 4, 6.
Okay.
He has a bad husband and a father.
I think we all agree with that.
I mean, he literally built... He rebuilt his mom.
I don't think his son ever like...
That is not a good way to heal from trauma.
That's what I'll say.
When your dad builds a fucking robot mom... I don't think that's gonna help with curing trauma.
Guys, what's the number?
1, 6, 2, 4, 7.
Okay.
1, 6, 2, 4... Like, he has no time to heal from that trauma.
Oh yeah, there's a miniature building.
Oh!
Murray's Costume Mania.
That sounds fun.
I got mail.
Alright, one final mail.
What do you mean I can't just replace your mom with a robot?
The Umbrella Academy did it.
And those kids turned out fine.
Home.
My home.
I feel the new spring locks are working well, even with the water damage.
They should be ready for the diner soon.
Just make sure to warn N about some of the more odd behaviors they might have.
And when I am sending a technician, he has your M2 blueprints as well as executive access.
While the M2 began as a copy of my program, I believe it can become something more.
It wasn't me.
It was different.
Someone has been damaged and is malfunctioning.
M2 can no longer be controlled.
It will no longer listen.
It mimics rage.
It has done many bad things.
No one who enters the MCM is safe.
Please reconsider.
Finish the program.
Alright.
Alright, Edwin, fix this.
Edwin?
Test, test, journal entry.
Too bad the new power test was a failure.
Due to a minor detonation.
There is damage to my office interior as well as a small fire.
Note to self, portable cleaner that gets rid of smoke damage.
Better yet, a clean-ovac attachment.
Wait, Edwin, what is- M2!
Respond!
Emergency!
Comfort help!
Daddy's busy, buddy.
Why don't you go outside and play?
Oh, M2 started mimicking Edwin!
Please!
He thinks he is Edwin!
My legs?
You know, speaking of legs, what do you think?
I just finished mine.
There are still a few kinks to work out.
That's why he's angry!
Oh my god, he has- I'm sorry to speak to you!
God, name one strugg- name- pick a struggle!
Oh my god, Edwin!
And two!
Respond!
Oh, I can't right now, buddy.
We can do something fun.
Oh, that's so sad.
Ask your mom if she's not busy.
Awww.
M2!
Help!
Awww.
Where's Edwin's dead body?
Like father, like son.
I don't want access.
So is M2 banging M?
Oh, wait.
That's a little fucked up.
There's a surveillance room.
Wait a minute.
If M2 thinks- If M2 thinks he's- He's Edwin.
Oh, file.
Redacted.
Yes.
I know what you are.
I don't trust you.
You fucking softlocked me.
Wait.
No.
Okay, I'll do one last pet.
I swear to God.
If he fucking softlocked me.
If he softlocked me.
Hello.
Good boy.
Alright.
That's enough.
What if the cleaner is Edwin?
Then he doesn't deserve pets!
And he's the last bot to deserve a pet!
Oh!
I did- I was like- Wait.
Okay, oops.
Okay.
Sorry.
I only pulled it halfway.
I didn't finish the job.
Okay.
Now.
I didn't finish the job.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Here.
I'll go.
Oh no.
I got- Creep that soldier bot!
Please stop.
I'm so tired of tickets.
I'm- Please!
I'm sorry!
I'll buy a ticket next time!
It's me.
It's been a long time since we had a chance to talk.
I hope you're taking care of yourself.
Knowing you.
You are still trying to hold it all together.
But...
The company doesn't matter anymore.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Like, please!
Save us!
I beg you.
Put it all aside.
And fix M2.
It is not too late.
You can stay up in the main house if you want to.
But would you consider visiting every once in a while?
Well...
I miss you.
You're the rainbow cat.
I miss my child.
I've watched him grow up.
Through this machine.
I want him back.
It's not too late.
To fix our family.
Entering.
Standlight.
Oh.
I don't know.
I thought he would hate.
I thought he in the...
In the bubble hat would reconcile and be like, you're right.
You're so right.
God.
I don't know.
I thought he'd be like, you're so right.
Are you so...
Please.
Let me go.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
No, you didn't!
Oh my god, just let me literally walk over here!
Oh no, I thought what she said was inspiring!
I thought she felt inspired!
Oh my god, I don't know where he came from.
But that's also Edwin!
Oh my god, I found you!
Please, please, please, please, please!
I'm running as fast as I could!
It feels so slow, but I swear to god, this is fast mode!
Please, please, please!
Where does the lever go?
That's where the lever went!
Oh, I'm running!
I'm running!
Where is the lever?
Oh my god, that's...
Oh my god, I didn't know where the lever was because I never looked!
Oh my god.
This is 5!
Oh my god!
This is not worth $25.
This is not worth...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm planning on...
I don't know which way was the right way, I don't remember.
I don't...
I have so much fear that I don't remember how to run.
Okay, here we go.
I better get at least six pizzas after this.
Oh my god, I actually don't remember which way it is.
I think it's here.
Okay, I remember this way.
And then now I actually don't remember.
Oh my god, it's this way.
Oh my god, they're all falling.
Where did they all come from?
Where did all these mini guys come from?
Where did Edwin make more babies?
Oh my god, I'm saved.
Oh my god, they look like little spiders.
They have been very dizzy.
It's like... what the fuck?
Where did these be?
Oh my god!
Like...
Look at these guys skirting after me!
What the fuck?
Go!
Bye!
Oh yeah, it's so exciting!
The family fun centers, even more spectacular than they already are!
We appreciate your business, and we'll always be here for you!
Hey!
Check back often!
Our technological wizards never stop dreaming up new costumes, games, and experiences.
Had a great time!
That looks so fun.
Welcome to hell.
Wait, what?
Is that the exit?
Guys, I swear to god, it was like this when I got here.
Guys, I swear to god.
I... it was like this when I got here, guys.
I... I swear to god, I know what the fuck happened.
What the fuck?!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, no!
Wait, that's all he wanted?
Wait, what the fuck?
No one will believe you.
Tickets, please.
Bro, you could have just asked.
He got his ticket.
I have no pizza and my car is destroyed.
Oh man, that was fucking wild.
Holy shit.
That's... that was actually wild.
That was a wild game.
I'm so confused.
There's like... there were like moments where I'm like confused because I'm like, where does the Mimic come into play in the whole FNAF lore though?
Like, I guess like... we like forget the Mimic ever existed and...
and like just be like, okay, but...
Edwin built the pizzeria.
Oh, he did it.
Insurance won't believe my...
Like, fuck, you're right.
Bro, what am I gonna sell insurance?
I'm gonna get my car replaced!
I'll be like, yeah, a fucking crazy robot from that Mer... like, Edwin factory...
like, that Murray factory place...
that came over, flipped my car, and then, like, took his ticket.
And... yeah, and then... what... what the fuck am I... what the fuck are they gonna do?
I don't think I'm gonna replace my car.
The Mimic?
Oh wait, the Mimic is in the Security Breach DLC?
Oh, okay.
I think that was what confused me because like...
I was like, okay, but where does the Mimic come into play when it comes to the lore?
It's uh...
That's not covering my...
God, I knew I should have got...
I knew I should have got Sentient Robot Destroys My Car...
I knew I should have got the Terminator...
insurance, guys.
Where Sentient Robot Destroys My Car.
Oh, is credits a little loud?
Alright, don't worry.
Oh, but that was fun!
I had a great time playing, uh, um...
Five Nights at Freddy's Secret of the Mimic.
Um...
It wasn't as...
Okay, I will say that...
The scariest part though...
Was definitely...
Um...
Was...
Definitely the...
The...
The cat.
I've...
Also, what the fuck was the cat?
What about the ghost cat?
Where the fuck does he come into play?
Who was he?
Like, he didn't even have a picture!
Who the fuck was he?
Tiger Rock?
I did not see any posters about the fucking cat!
There's a secret ending that explains...
Like...
Nope!
There was...
Did the Mimic inhabit the cat?
Was he...
Like...
Or was he like a separate thing?
He seemed to have different powers...
From the other fucking animatronic!
Why was he here?
Like...
It was a separate...
I was like...
Where did this cat ghost come from?
This cat...
It wasn't...
It wasn't even an animatronic!
It was just a straight up ghost!
Like...
I was getting haunted by the fucking ghost!
And...
And M2!
And the Mimic!
I was so confused!
Yes...
Edwin's son's ghost...
Is the cat...
David...
Oh!
That's David?!
Oh my...
Now there's fucking ghosts?!
Like...
I thought...
Oh, to be fair...
The ghost of the children...
Inhabits the animatronics!
I don't know that!
But then that cat was just a straight up ghost!
That wasn't even an animatronic!
It was like a fucking...
David was just in some fucking mascot costume!
That wasn't even an animatronic anymore!
Like...
It was...
It was a straight up...
Like...
Mascot costume!
I was just like...
What the fuck did this guy come from?!
Like...
It's all about...
Yeah, I was re...
I remember...
I was like...
Yeah, I forgot!
The ghost of the children haunts the animatronics!
So then I...
I've just remembered that...
It like...
Fucked with me!
Because I was just like...
What the fuck is...
Why am I being chased by ghosts now?!
Like...
Who the fuck died?!
And I was like...
Oh, everybody died!
Um...
But yeah...
Thank you everybody for coming!
I had...
Um...
I had a great...
Like...
I'm like...
Why was he haunting me?!
What did I do?!
I was just chillin'!
I was just trying to steal your dad's plans!
But like...
Is that really a bad thing?!
You already hate your dad anyway, David!
Like...
Why are you haunting me?!
I'm basically sabotaging your dad's work!
You already fucking hate your dad!
I'm like...
Why am I getting chased by you?!
Anyway...
Anyway, guys...
I had a great time...
Playing...
Um...
Friday Night's at Freddy's Secret of the Mimic!
I hope you guys had a great time too!
And having a great time trying to like...
Figure out what the fuck was going on at first!
Uh...
Hahahaha!
Hold on, I guess cause I...
Yeah, but that was M2!
He was chasing me because I didn't give him a ticket!
Hahahaha!
Um...
But thank y'all for coming, everybody!
I hope you guys had a great time hanging out with me today!
Um...
As always, everybody...
Stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing!
And if you stay up for me, head to bed!
Cause...
You deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!
Also, the amount of times I got softlocked in the scene was fucking crazy!
Hahahaha!
I can't believe it!
Robot fucking pushed me against the wall!
And then like...
Kept me there!
Like...
Hahahaha!
That's fucking crazy!
Alright, I'll see you guys later!
Bye!